Four 3 two one
and are we
live yes you're live live sorry but I
just had a big firework and I wondered
if that had been picked up do apologize
so good evening and welcome to this
annual council meeting on Thursday the
5th of November 2020 and I apologize if
you heard the explosions my neighbors
are appearing to have a little bit of a
firework party well just the family my
name is councelor Penny Channer and I'm
the vice chairman of the molden district
council this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of April in response to the coid
19 situation and there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through first
of all please could I ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off when not addressing the council
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional
disturbances this meeting will be hosted
remotely streamed live and recorded and
by being present in the meeting you are
given consent to being
recorded members and officers during
each item please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time to obviously speak
speak members are reminded that apart
from indicating you wish to speak or
that you have to leave the meeting the
chat function really should not be used
for any other
purpose please do not use the raiseed
hand function as this is not available
on all of the member
devices members the process this evening
will obviously be different and for some
items I may invite each member to speak
in turn therefore I would encourage all
members to keep your contributions as
clear and as succinct concise as
possible please when invited to speak
please ensure you turn on your
microphone and
camera when speaking and referring to
the agender papers please ensure you
reference a page or a paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point please do make this
known and use the chat function to
signify that you need to leave the
meeting now if I may please can I ask
officers taking part in the meeting to
please introduce themselves and I
believe uh I've got first of all Mr
Dodson
please or Mr Holmes sorry I beg your
pardon good evening name is uh Richard
Holmes director of Service delivery
thank
you Mr Dodson now good evening members
Paul Dodson director of strategy
performance and governance
Mr quelch
please uh Simon quelch and I'm giving
legal advice thank you Simon Mr Co
rather Mr butcher
please thank you chairman Steven butcher
commercial
manager Miss Bird please good evening
chairman good evening members Tara bird
committee Services officer thank
you and can I please ask are there any
other officers present that I may have
not called please if you're here could
you please introduce yourselves now very
grateful okay silence means there no one
else so thank you very much now members
we're now going to ask Tara uh Tara bird
or rather Miss Bird please if you can
call out a roll call calling members in
alphabetical order and can I ask you if
you can to unmute your microphone at
that time and your video so you can be
seen as well if possible thank you very
much Miss bird thank you chairman
members if you could just indicate if
you're present when I call your name
starting with councelor Bamford
please good evening Tara I'm here good
evening thank you councelor
Bassinger good evening everyone I'm
present councelor Miss
Bill
present
branville good evening everyone I'm
present councelor
Bell good evening everybody I'm
Boyce
present councelor Mrs CH obviously pres
yes hello I'm
here councelor
diick councelor
Durham uh I'm present Tara thank you
thank you very much councel
Edwards
present councelor Mrs Fleming present
Tara counc
fluka I'm present thank you Miss B and
and just for your information uh
councelor duick is actually on sick
leave thank you you apologies then and
councelor
herd good evening Tara members I'm
present evening thank you very much
councelor Helm present Tara councelor
H um present Tara thank you very much
J evening Tara members even councelor
Keys good evening Tara good evening
members present evening thank you much
councelor lagen
yeah good evening everybody I'm present
ARA thank you councelor
Ma present Tara good evening good
evening thank you councelor
Morris I think you forgot councelor
moley but um Chrissy Morris all present
and
correct Moy I do
apologize not a problem present Tara
thank you very much councelor
n yes president Tara good evening Tara
good evening members thank you
sh uh good evening everyone good evening
Tara
present councelor Sidle good evening
Tara good evening members present good
evening thank you very much councilor
schemes yeah good evening everybody um I
saw on the screen somebody called
Anonymous I was just wondering who
Anonymous might be
um I believe chairman we have a member
that's dialed in I think that who that's
who that might
be that's me chairman oh it's councelor
Miss White councelor Miss White good
evening councelor
stamp good evening chairman good evening
Tara good evening members good evening
thank you councilor
St good evening everybody present Tara
much councelor
Swain yes present good evening evening
thank you councelor Mrs
Thompson sorry t a bit slow there yes
president thank you good evening
everyone and pleas confirmed she's
already in
attendance thank you chairman that is
the roll call done thank you very much
thank you very much and you've got the
apologies I think that councelor fluka
has identified yes I have noted those
thank you then members please we turn
now to agenda item number two which is
election of of chairman and would you
just let me finish what I'm about to say
I'd be very grateful so members I will
now call for nominations for a chairman
of the council for the remainder of the
municipal year to May
2021 once appointed I will hand over
proceedings to the new chairman members
before we proceed can you please ensure
your videos and microphones are turned
off then I'm going to now ask any member
wishing to nominate to the position of
chairman of the council to please unmute
your microphone turn on your video and
state your name and
nomination
n if there is more than one nomination I
will request a second for each
nomination in the order they will
received so any member wishing to Second
nominations please can I please now see
who's um wants to nominate councelor
none I can see on chat you wish to
nominate that's the Miss bird is that
the first
one uh yes chairman he was yes right
councelor nun thank you very much
chairman uh councelor nun I would like
to nominate councelor Mark herd as
chairman uh for the remainder of the
municipal
year thank
you I believe there's some more wishing
to nominate I'll come back for a second
is in a minute um I see councelor
Fleming thank you chairman I'm nominate
councelor Chana I nominate councelor
Chana because she is the most suitable
candidate for the job because of the
coid 19 situation in reality we're not
uh electing a chair to carry out Civic
functions we need a chair who can run an
orderly meeting knows the Constitution
and the authority inside out the
appointment is for the remainder of the
Civic year and until some normality
returns councelor Cher is already doing
the job and she's doing a good job we
need a safe Pair of Hands thank you
thank you um right nowara I can't see
any more on my chat can you see any
others wishing to nominate I'm not on
the chat chairman no thank you in that
case count uh councel nun has and I'll
take them in the order they are
councilor nun has proposed counselor her
is that second wish
to
I yeah I think I know who that who
animal that might be is it yours or is
it the other member mine I know it is
yes we were advised unfortunately and it
was I won't give the councel name they
did say because of their fireworks there
could be some K9 interventions which
they Madam chairman it's not mine no
okay right I take that back then in that
case then Council Nan has um proposed
Council Mark herd is that seconded
please if so can I ask you to turn on
your uh right is that councelor sta
yes please chairman I'd like to Second
councelor Mark herd to be the chairman
thank you much chairman would you like
me to say why I think councelor herd
would be or should we just leave it you
want to yes if you want to no I don't
think so I think he deserves it but
thank you for the opportunity chair no
okay CH can we have a recorded vote
please uh yes can I just ask if you can
I just hold on a minute please councelor
Fleming has um nominated councelor Chana
is that seconded please and if chairman
I'm happy to I'm happy to second is that
councelor
Durham right thank thank you uh
councilor Fleming has requested a a
recorded vote is that
seconded seconded thank you right in
that case uh I then ask Miss Bird please
if you could take um the uh votes and
we'll do it in the order that the names
were given to council so therefore we we
have uh on the first one uh nominated by
councelor Steven Nun seconded by
councelor Wendy stamp councelor heard so
T if I could hand over to you please sir
chairman just confirm you want me to
take individually or do you want me just
members to indicate who they're voting
for I I think we'll as it's recorded I
think we'll do each individually
individually individually pleas no
problem at all I think that's how the
recorded vote should be done yes that's
fine so the first vote please for um
councilor herd then members um I call
your names up um alphabetically if you
could just indicate if you're for
against or abstaining please I'm
starting with councelor Bamford please
against thank you councelor
Bassinger for thank you councelor Miss
B
against thank you councelor Brian
Bill four thank you councelor bell four
thank you councelor Boyce
against councelor Mrs
chel
against councelor jick sorry he's not
here councel Durham
against
EDS
for councelor Mrs Fleming against thank
you councelor
Fluker
against councelor herd
four you councelor helm
against
Hull against counc
Jarvis
abstain the
key
again councelor
lagen four thank you councelor
Maz
for councel
moley against thank you C counc
Morris definitely for thank you
councelor
none
four councelor
shaes four thank you councelor Sidle
four councelor schemes four but did I
hear councilor fluka vote vote and is he
allowed to
vote yes he is he's allowed to have be
at Council and he is allowed to vote
yes thank you councilor
four STS four coun Swain four councelor
Mrs
Thompson sorry I can't find the button
um against thank you and councelor Miss
White against thank you chairman the
result of that is 40 sorry 15 for 13
against and one
exstension right let's record Ed vote I
think we have to go one at a time just
to make I can see what the vote is but I
think that as I understand it should
happen Okay chairman so you want me to
do the vote for
um yes please yes okay no problem and
same CL again please members uh
councelor
banford this is voting for Mrs Channer
as chairman now doing me I'm going to do
it recorded vote for
both so this is a vote for councilor CH
as chair yes that's right yes and I'm
for that thank you
Tara
passenger against you councelor
MV for thank you councelor Brian
B
against Bell
for Edwards
against councelor Mrs Fleming four
councelor Fluker four
her
against counselor hel
for coun
hall
four councelor
Jarvis
abstain keys
for councelor
lagen
against
maze
moley
for
Morris
against councelor
none
sha
against Sid
against against you councelor stamp
against councelor stils
against counc Swain against counc M
Thompson for and councelor Miss White
for very much and the results of that
chairman are 13 for 15 against and one
abstention thank you thank you very much
Miss bird therefore um on that voting I
declare that councelor Mark herd has
succeeded and is the new chairman of the
molden district council just before I
asked councel herd to make his
Declaration of office can I please just
save my time as Vice chairman has been
very enjoyable and I did follow in the
great big footsteps of councelor Bob
Boyce um who was the chairman before me
but I'm the vice chairman I've had to
fall in for reasons um in the latter
part since August but can I please thank
all members for the support that you
have given me can I also thank the
officers all of them and I would have to
single out probably miss bird here who
is absolutely marvelous regarding these
meetings so I just wanted to say thank
you very much for giving me the
opportunity to have been the vice
chairman of this Council and I now hand
over uh to uh Council herd and if you'd
allow me to just say that now it's
agenda item three councilor herd and
members of the council the Chairman's
statutory Declaration of acceptance of
office chairman before you move on I I
wanted to actually say something can I
say something see your hand up yes I'll
let you
I I'd like to thank you for stepping up
when councelor Boyce um resigned from
his position I actually do think you've
been done an excellent job um I actually
think you're an excellent chairman as
well and I'd like to thank you from
behalf of many many people and
counselors on this Council you stood up
it was a difficult situation and and
thank you thank you chairman no thank
you Council stamp that's very much
appreciated I think being you know in
these positions it it can be difficult
but that's why it's important to have
the support of members and the support
of good officers and our offices are
exceptional let me tell this Council the
members of the public we are blessed to
have exceptional officers so thank you
very much to all of you and Miss bird
you know how I think about you I always
sent you a thank you after the meeting
you I'm indebted to you for allowing me
to try and master this technology while
we're having virtual meetings yes so uh
councelor herd please uh now we have to
go through a post
process of the Declaration of acceptance
of office and can I just say um and I
think my part do this that members and
members of the public please note that
as this meeting is being held virtually
and due to current restrictions as a
result of coid 19 it will not be
possible for the chairman and vice
chairman of the council chains of office
to be handed over to the newly appointed
post holders normally what would happen
we'd be in the chamber and I would be
able or uh the chairman I suppose in the
absence of chairman I be do be able to
place the chain of office around
councelor herd's neck and likewise for
subsequent positions but unfortunately I
do hope everyone appreciates the
difficulties and the challenging times
we're all working in we have to make
sure we keep everyone safe that's staff
members and residents so um so that so
what I would say as soon as arrangements
for the chains of office to be received
at a later date accordingly that will be
arranged
so I will now call on councelor Mark
herd to make the statutory Declaration
of acceptance of the office of the
chairman and I will vacate the chair
following that uh declaration councelor
herd please can I before you go on
Madame chairman you are still chairman
as the current leader I'd like to thank
you very very much for everything you've
done as well and thank you for councelor
stamp for doing the same very much
appreciated all the work you've done
thank you very much
here to all of that thank you everyone
thank you Council councelor
herd can you are you there councelor
herd I am indeed chairman thank you very
much okay um if you could make your
Declaration of office please I'm Mark
Steven herd having been elected to the
office of chairman of the Council of the
District of mden declare that I will
take that office upon myself and I will
duly and Faithfully fulfill the duties
in it according to the best of my
judgment and ability I undertake to
observe the code as to the conduct which
is expected of members of molden
District
Council I will now sign the
form and date it and that form will be
handed to the
directors okay congratulations councilor
herd and at this point I'm going to go
on mute and and shut my video down and I
hand over now um to you councelor herd
for the rest of the meeting thank you
very
much thank you very much
indeed and thank you
members thank you members as the new
chairman I will now call for the
nominations to Vice chairman of the
council for the remainder of the
municipal year to May
2021 any member wishing to uh second uh
the nomination that I'm going to make
from the chair which is councelor maiz
please unmute your microphone turn on
your video and state your
name councelor stamp yes please I would
like to Second the nomination of Carly
Mays to councelor Carly Mays to be
appointed Vice chair thank
you thank you very much are there any
other
nominations okay in the absence of any
other nominations I declare that
councelor Carly Mays uh is the vice
chairman of molden District
Council
congratulations congratulations to you
um do we need to take a vote on that
Tara
um chairman you can vote on it can be
done by asent whichever You' preer or
whichever members would
prefer okay is that uh is that agreed by
Ascent agreed agreed agreed I think we
would prefer chair chairman I think we
would prefer to take a vote on
that very well Tara if you could uh do
the roll call
please recorded vote chairman recorded
vote please recorded vote if you second
the recorded vote okay we'll have a
recorded vote thank you thank you
chairman so this is voting for Council
ma as Vice chairman if you could just
indicate for against or abstaining when
I call your name please starting with
Council bford please
against thank you very much councel
M against thank you councelor Brian bill
four councelor bell four you councelor
Boyce
obain councel Mrs
CH
against Council
Daren uh against Tara thank you
councelor Edwards for thank you
councelor Mrs Fleming against thank you
councelor fluka
against councelor
her
for thank you councelor
Helm against Tara thank you counselor
[Music]
H oh
abstain councelor
Jarvis
Keys
against councelor Lagan
four counc ma four thank you councelor
moley
against
morrris wholeheartedly for thank you
canel
none
four
shy SLE
four celor schemes
four Cel St
four councilor ma works really hard and
she deserves it thank you thank
you four thank you councelor Swain four
thank you councelor Mrs
Thompson against councelor Miss
White against thank you thank you
chairman the results of that are 15 for
11 against and three extensions thank
you chairman thank you very much in that
case I I do declare um Council ma as
Vice chairman of the council and I will
now call on her to make the statutory
Declaration of acceptance of the office
of Vice chairman of the council
councilor
Maz thank you very much Mr chairman um I
councelor Carly May having been elected
to the office of Vice chairman of the
Council of the District of molden
declare that I take the office upon
myself and will duy and Faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability I
undertake to observe the code as to the
conduct which is expected of members of
molden District Council I'm now going to
sign the
form and date it the 5th of November
2020 you can see that not sure you can
um that be sent um to the appropriate
person thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much um councel
CH you've indicate if you wish to
speak uh thank you very much um I'll say
congratulations to council amaz and I
can assure you I'll make sure the badge
of office which I've currently got on Al
I'm going to take it right off now um I
will make sure that with arrangements
with officers that can be handed over so
Council ma can have it as soon as
possible um so just should there be
anything that she needs to be attending
or any well virtually or otherwise but
I'll make sure um that's arranged with
officers as soon as possible thank you
thank you very much um councelor Channer
I appreciate that chairman thank you
very much um agenda item number six is
apologies for absence may I have any
apologies for absence please Tara oh yes
chairman apologies have been Reed from
councelor duick thank you very much
thank you very much indeed agenda item
number seven
is Declarations of
Interest this is to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other peun interests
or non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraphs 6 to8 inclusive of
the code of conduct for members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interests as soon
as they become aware should the need
arise throughout the meeting if any
member has an interest to declare please
use the chat function now to
indicate and I will invite you to
speak Torah can you advise if any other
member has indicated a wish to speak oh
yes chairman councelor Mrs Channer
has thank you councelor chna thank you
very much chairman um I will declare um
I'm I'm referring now to the main
reports of uh this meeting following it
all we've dealt with all the meetings
except the special meetings so those
reports on the agenda I will be
declaring non-pecuniary chairman my
normal one as a a member of Essex County
Council as well purely because there
could be some association with some of
the matters so I'd feel more comfortable
declaring because obviously we do work
in Partnership quite a bit with essics
or we have dialogue with them so I'm
declaring to to for those items of the
main reports chairman that come at the
end of the meeting thank you very much
chairman and the uh one and the
confidential um item as well thank you
chair thank you very much um any other
members Tara chairman councelor Durham
is the other person that's indicated
thank you thank you councelor
Durham uh thank you very much chairman
and can I offer you my congratulations
um uh I declare non pecuniary interest
as a member of ESS County Council um
mainly pertaining to items 21 to 24 on
the agenda this evening thank
you thank you very much any other any
other members have they indicated
Tara and no chairman that's all okay
thank you very much we'll move on then
to agenda item number eight which are
minutes from the 1st of October 2020 and
it's recommended that the minutes of
this meeting found on pages 9 to 22 are
approved as a true and accurate record I
so move if you wish to second that if
you wish to second that motion please
turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now if
any member
wishes excuse me chairman I'd like
there's a mistaken uh on page
17 Page 17 item 20 um the resignation of
councelor Harker um you're missing the b
word and it's not the b word that
councelor Thompson would use it's uh
Basin hybridge Basin Parish Council
should be referred to and not hybridge
Parish
Council thank you that is correct Mr
chairman thank you very much that's
noted um are there any other uh any
other Corrections on that yes thank you
chairman councilor Swain yes I'm afraid
I can't use the chat function at the
moment
um yes on the minutes um for agenda item
eight which is on page 1415 concerned
the um scoping report I am put down as
um voting both for and against um it
should only be a vote for if that can be
corrected okay um can that be corrected
please
Tara oh yes of course CH we can make
sure that both those amendments get made
for you thank you very much any other
members wish to comment on the
minutes uh in that case uh do you wish
to agree those by Ascent agreed yes
agreed agreed agreed agreed agreed aged
agreed
aged thank you very much um agenda item
nine are public questions Tara have we
been notified of any public
questions no chairman we have got no
public question questions for tonight
thank you thank you very much um agenda
item number 10 is uh Chairman's
announcements um if you would indulge me
for one moment uh I would like to thank
members for nominating me as chairman of
molden District Council for the
remainder of this Municipal year this is
an historic change for this Council
which has never before seen an
independent administ ation I thank
councelor Boyce and councelor channa for
their past chairmanship and I will
strive to serve this community fairly
and truthfully I have great admiration
for past counselors Henry bass Frank
delderfield and Robert long and I hope
to follow in their footsteps as
excellent chairman of this District my
theme will be one of unity and despite
our differences I hope we can work
together to rebuild the reputation of
this Council and build trust with its
officers staff and the public this is an
opportunity for us all to work together
push aside personal differences and
benefit the
community thank you very
much
um the second item here is uh members on
the 21st of October an email was
received from Nick shuttleworth uh
executive director of the rural
Community Council of essic thanking
councelor Mrs Penny Channer for
attending their AG councelor Channer
would you like to read this
out
think mute oh I'm off mute sorry
chairman I I have had a bit of
difficulty there do apologize I'll just
try and find it if I may chairman um I'm
happy for you to read out or if you want
me to but if you'd like to I'm quite
okay with that as you're the chairman
thank you very much I do I do have it
here
um so Nick shuttleworth executive
director of the rural community council
of essics writes to Mrs Channer I felt I
must write to thank you so much for
finding the time in your busy schedule
to join us for our annual general
meeting last Wednesday evening it means
a lot to us when Civic leaders take the
trouble to attend our AGM especially
this year when we had to hold it
virtually I hope you found it
interesting and an informative occasion
and we're able to find out more about
the work
RCC is currently doing to support and
sustain rural communities throughout
Essex our guest speaker Professor Jules
pretty provided another dimension to the
event with a thought-provoking and
challenging presentation thank you again
for support supporting
RCC and
uh members uh can I now hand you over to
the director of Service delivery for an
update on coid
19 thank you chairman uh members will be
aware that from one minute past midnight
this morning England entered a period of
Lockdown from the 5th of November to the
2nd of December following the public
announcement from the Prime Minister on
Saturday officers have been working on
our necessary response to the lockdown
ministerial briefings were held on
Sunday and planning work by the
corporate and extended leadership team
commenced over the weekend the
government has now introduced the
legislation and detailed guidance to
cover this
period officers have Revisited
arrangements and broadly grouped the
necessary response to the latest
situation on the following headings
Public Health that's working with our
partners to maintain public health
support and advice to business and
undertaking inspections as required our
commercial activities incorporating
Leisure centers and all of our other
services to priy by the council
our customer services including adapting
or public contact with either in person
online or telephone we're also looking
at supporting vulnerable people and
that'll be working with our CVS who will
be supporting the extremely clinically
vulnerable those that were formerly
Sheltering in lockdown and also
assisting homeless persons we are also
supporting businesses in two parts the
administration and payments of
government grants and to support to
local business operations including the
adaptation of Wen High Street we're also
working on our corporate Communications
including public contact through the
social media and websites member
Communications and internal staff
Communications and finally service
monitoring managing the impact of the
additional Co work on our business as
usual activities monitoring budget
control and monitoring the health and
well-being of our staff the council has
continued to engage at a strategic level
within Essex working with Partners to
manage this pandemic and this activity
has stepped up recently the council will
continue to provide its Frontline
services but unlike the first lockdown
some services are unaffected play sites
public conveniences and cemeteries for
example but our Leisure centers have had
to close as of
today finally as head ofid service I'd
like to look inward just for a moment
most staff of the council have been
working remotely since March the
council's extended leadership team has
ensured welfare and support is available
during these challenging times however
pressure continues to grow on services
on highlight just one area during this
pandemic the council has administered a
number of business grants for the
government the work has required intense
preparation at short notice and handled
millions of pounds in payments and dealt
with inquiries and appeals this work of
course is in addition to the normal
workload by the team this week alone two
more Grant schemes have been announced
all of which need the same level of work
in attention to detail I stress that all
of the staff of the council working
flexibly have been adaptable and ensured
services have continued to be provided
to our community since March and will
continue to do so corporate leadership
team would like to put on record our
thanks to all of the staff working for
the council during this challenging
period thank you
chairman thank you Mr
holes um Council Swain you still got
your hand up is that left over from your
previous inquiry
please thank you very much uh we'll move
on now to uh agenda item number 11 which
is the minute book uh this uh this is
found on pages 22 to
36 first one is sorry chairman before
move on I did put my hand up I just
wanted to as the current leader I just
wanted to express my thanks to the
officers who've worked extremely hard
during all this pandemic um and it
continues to um encroach upon the normal
day-to-day running of the council
they've done a lot of work and there is
still a great deal of work to be done
and I thank them for their dedication
thank
you thank you Council banford I'll
straight back to you I'll be coming
straight back to you
actually actually Mr chairman if if I
may also come in um as um Vice chair of
stress and resources um who I know I had
to take over the stress resources
committee again I'd like to put thank
the officers for the hard work they've
done throughout the um coid crisis um
and you know thank them for their time
with the live world board in making a
molden a better place to live and I
think mustn't forget whoever's actually
um in charge of the council that we work
with the officers and work for the
benefit of our residents and not to
settle scores um and I'm sure that we
will do working forward thank
you well I certainly hope that's the
case councelor white thank you uh so
we'll now move on to the minute book
found on pages 22 to 36 this is
performance governance and audit from
the 24th of September uh 2020 these are
on pages 23 to 32 councilor Bamford to
present the minutes if any member wishes
to raise any matter of accuracy please
use the chat function and I will invite
you to
speak thank you
chairman it's uh elain banford again who
is the who is the current chairman of
performance governance and audit
committee and I'm presenting the minutes
of the performance governance and audit
committee of the four 24th of September
which were held remotely um and I'll go
through Page by Page um so page
23 page
24 page
25 page
26 page
27 page
28 page
29 page 30 and Page 31 chairman and I um
propose that they're adopted thank you
thank you has any me any member wished
to speak on that please
Tara um no chairman no one's indicated I
wish to speak thank you okay um can we
take it then members that you wish to
agree those minutes by
Ascent agreed agreed agreed agreed
agre thank you very much uh I now move
to the overview and scrutiny meeting
held on the 15th of October 2020 these
are found on pages 33 to 36 councilor
Hound to present the minutes and one
recommendation contained in minute six
committee operating and working
practices councelor
Helm are you there councelor h
I'm getting there it's modern
technology I wish to present the minutes
of the overview and scrutiny committee
held on the 15th of October
2020 on page
33 page
34 page
35 and Page 36 I so
move thank thank you Tara has anyone
indicated that they wish to speak please
no chairman no one has thank you thank
you very much um can we Mr
chair I'm
sorry thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you Council H thank you um are we
able to agree those by Ascent
members agreed agreed aged agreed
agreed thank you very much
we now move on
to
agenda oh yes and the recommendation
contained within are are we able to
agree
that agreed agreed
agreed thank you very much we'll move on
now to agenda item 12 which is minutes
of meetings of the
council and this is to note that since
the last meeting of the council and up
until Wednesday the 28th of October
2020 the Committees listed have met and
to receive any questions in accordance
with Council and committee procedure
rules
62 um if any member wishes to raise a
question in relation to the minutes of
this meeting please make this known by
using the chat function within this
meeting T has anyone indicated that they
wish to speak no chairman no one has
indicated they wish to speak thank
you thank you very much uh is everybody
happy to agree those by
asent yes agreed agreed agreed agreed
agreed thank you very much uh agenda
item
13 uh this is questions in accordance
with procedure rule 62 of which notice
have been given um I don't think there
are any could you confirm that please
Tara that's right chairman we haven't
received any thank you thank you very
much indeed okay agender item 14 uh are
leaders and composition of political
groups and we move to this uh item which
was circulated today and this is found
in the supplementary pack Pages 7 to8 in
a moment I will introduce this
item so members if you wish to speak on
this item to make this known by using
the chat function on this meeting uh
please I will come to you in turn keep
your points clear and suent
please I seem have lost my place on this
one now with me a
sec chairman if I could perhaps help um
I believe the leader was going to
introduce the
report yes I'm just trying to find it on
my on my notes here but uh yes I could
ask the leader to introduce the report
and move the recommendations as set out
in the
report thank you chairman um just to
explain for any members of the public
that might be listening to this meeting
um I am the current leader of MN
District Council but um the leader
designate which is the first
recommendation which is to ratify the
leader designate as leader of the
council is in fact the
leader of the independence because they
are the largest group on the council at
this point so chairman I will um go to
you to put the recommendation
one to ratify the leader designate as
leader of the council thank you very
much
recommendations thank you the
recommendations are set out in the
report as follows that the council can
considers ratification of the leader
designate councelor Wendy stamp as
leader of the
council
secondly well is that
seconded yes I second that Mr uh
chairman could we have a recorded vote
please chairman and I'll second that as
well yes we will have a uh are we going
to take these recommendations um
separately Tara
um yes chman would suggest that you did
yes yes I I think you should okay thank
you very much so we'll go for a recorded
vote uh and this is
uh to assign the leader leader designate
councilor Wendy stamp as leader of
molden District Council if you could
take the vote please Tara thank
you thank you chairman members if you
could indicate for against or abstain U
and this is a vote for ratification of a
leader designate as leader of the
council starting with councelor Bamford
please against thank you councel
Bassinger
oh miss
bill
against councelor Brian bill
for councel bell for thank you councelor
Boyce against thank you councelor Mrs
Channer against you counselor dorham
against Miss bird thank you very much
councelor Edwards for thank you
councelor Mrs Fleming against thank you
councelor
Fluker against Miss bird thank you very
much councelor Harker sorry oh I do
apologize that's totally wrong councelor
herd four thank you very much councelor
hel against Tara thank you councelor h
against
Tara
jvis
abstain
against the council
Lagan very much for please
Tara
foury against thank you councelor
Morris most definitely
four thank you councelor
shy four you councelor Sidle four thank
you councelor skem
four councelor stamp four you councelor
stilts four thank you councelor
Swain thank you Mrs Thompson against and
councelor Miss
White against thank you very much H
chairman the results of that are 154 13
against and one exstension thank you
very much thank you very much uh
therefore um I declare councelor Wendy
stamp as leader of molden District
Council and offer her my
congratulations thank you chairman thank
you members who voted for me thank you
very much
um I see that number two now uh is no
longer required uh so I'll go to agenda
item number recommendation number three
that the council elects the deputy
leader of the council and from the chair
I would propose councelor Steven nun is
that seconded uh yes Mr uh Mr chairman
it is seconded thank you councilor Ma I
will now uh invite uh any other
nominations are members happy to agree
by
Ascent uh yes agreed
agreed agreed agreed agreed can we have
a recorded vote please
chairman vote is that seconded I'll
second okay thank you
the roll call again please uh this is
uh councelor Steven nun as Deputy leader
of the
council thank you chairman members as
before if you could just indicate for
against or obstain please starting with
councel
bford
against councelor
Bassinger for councel Miss b i against
thank you councelor Brian bill
for thank you councelor Bell
for councelor Boyce
against Mrs
chna against you councelor
[Music]
Durham sorry C can't sorry was that me T
yes it was you yeah sorry um um um
against Miss bird thank you thank you
very much councelor Edwards for
thank you councelor Mrs Fleming against
thank you councelor Fluker against Miss
B councelor
herd
for councel
Helm against Tara thank you very much
councelor
hul against Tara thank you councelor
Jarvis
abstain you councelor keys against Sara
thank you
lag for Miss
bird counc ma
for councelor
moley
against councelor
Morris most definitely four thank you
very much councelor man four thank you
counc
shessy four Tara thank you councelor
Sidle four
thank you councelor schemes four thank
you councelor stamp four thank you
councelor
stilts
four
Twain four thank you councelor Mrs
Thompson against thank you and councelor
Miss White
against chairman the results of that
vote are 15 for 13 against and one
abstention thank you very much thank you
um in that case I declare councelor
Steven pan to be the deputy leader of
molden District Council and I offer my
congratulations to him chairman can I
also off offer my congratulations sorry
to interrupt you I I also offer my
congratulations to Steven nun and I look
forward to working with him and the
officers and everybody else in the in
the groups thank you for allowing
me thank thank you also uh chair and to
forward to working with uh uh councelor
stamp as her deputy and uh uh all of the
members and all of the officers uh and
let's hope that we move into a more
harmonious uh time thank you very
much chairman may I also extend my
congratulations to them
both thank you counc that very much
appreciated well done um okay so agenda
item 15 we now move to this agenda item
which is the appointment of membership
of uh Committees of the council this was
circulated today and is in the
supplementary pack the second part uh
which is Pages nine to 16 before I call
on the leader to introduce this item I
want to draw your attention to
recommendation uh little three where the
council is required to make a nomination
to certain
committees
uh Mr Dodson did you want to take this
from
here yes thank you well actually I think
I think the leader is going to present
the report is she not
okay um thank thank you um Mr chairman
um yes I would like to present this
report but I will immediately hand over
to councilor stamp Council of voice has
raised a point of order uh I'm obliged
to go to him um good evening Council of
voice um good evening chairman um I
won't show myself because the machine
says turn on video lose
connectivity
um the
the uh what I want I might be a bit
premature um uh in this because it
refers to the
um uh the agenda item 15 um in relation
to the area committees but I mean this
is um 15 and and it is the follow so
I'll give notice um chairman that I wish
to raise this issue uh and it's a
statute that I want to refer to rather
than our constitution thank you
chairman thank you than very much I'll
take it you'll come in at at that
particular time um so leader of the
council to present this report and move
the
recommendations set out in the report
councelor leader uh thank you chairman
um yes I'm I'm going to hand immediately
over to um Mr Dobson because um there
was we was called urgently this
afternoon and I think all members need
to hear what Mr Dobson has to say and
then I'll move the report and the rec
recommendations if that's the way it
goes chair thank you very much Mr
Dodson yes thank you Mr chairman um yes
obviously th this report um is um
intended to appoint the members to the
the Committees of the council and that's
done on the basis of political balance
as is set out within the
report and that's based on the um ation
of seats based on The Independents
having 15 members conservatives 10 um
and the Democratic Alliance um for
members the the figures are shown in 3.6
for each of the Committees based on
applying those figures to the individual
committees however I do want to point
out something to members that is um was
in all honesty noticed after the the
report was was
published and there's something called
principle C which as well as applying
those figures to each individual
committee we also have to look at the
number of seats across all of those
committees in the table shown in in um
3.6 and and look to see if the the
numbers still work so in
effect there are 64 seats across all of
those
committees and when you apply the the
figures to them it's absolutely correct
that The Independents have 32
conservatives
21 however the de Democratic Alliance
have been appointed to seven seats and
that are allocated seven seats and
that's based on rounding when you apply
their proportion of seats of the council
across all 64 of those seats it comes
out at 8
533 um seats and that the principle is
that it's rounded up so in effect that's
nine seats across all of those
committees rather than the seven that
are shown so that means that of the four
seats that are shown for Council
appointment two of those need to be
allocated to the Democratic Alliance to
ensure that we're um in compliance with
with principle C
so the um appendix sets out those
members who have been allocated by
leaders of groups to those um committees
and as I say there there are four um
floating seats as as it were where the
the numbers were tied between different
groups so we couldn't then allocate
those and those four need to be
appointed by Council and nominated by
Council and approved
but two of those at least for to ensure
the balance is correct need to be
appointed to the Democratic Alliance I
hope that's that's clear thank
you thank you very much um leader um yes
can I have some more advice from Mr
Dodson because I'd like to make a
proposal to the
recommendations uh but I'm not sure
exactly where it needs to go this as I
said it was a late hour of the day then
when we were given this
information um obviously the allocation
of seats little one recommendation
little one as set out in 3.6 below is
ratified uh but that needs to change
doesn't it Mr Dodson because we're going
through you chair answer on that I've
got another point of order from
councelor Durham which I'm Duty bound to
take so councelor Durham I'm I'm quite
happy just to let councelor stamp
continue her uh current argument and
then I'll come in after that thank you
okay I'm sorry to uh interrupt council's
uh leader I'm enjoying the interruptions
I'm sure it's uh an introduction for me
thank you chairman I'm sure I'll get
used to it um yes so do we put the
amendment to The Proposal um or at
little one because we will not be
ratifying that table because it is not
accurate now is it is that right Mr
Dodson it's right in as much as those
those name
in those positions can be appointed to
those I think the The Proposal that that
you're looking at should go at little
three that there are nomination where
nominations haven't been received to
appoint members to to those positions um
that's where there needs to be a pro
proposal around the two positions for
the um Democratic Alliance that they
proposed at that point which which
committees that they go into okay thank
thank you for your help Mr Dodson um
well the recommendation chair is that we
adopt uh little one little two uh but uh
I'd like to put Amendment for little
three uh I'd like to the debate to be
opened up uh before I put the
recommendation if members so
wish okay members if you wish to speak
on this item please make this known
using the chat function within this
meeting and I will then come to in turn
uh following uh the Leader's
presentation please keep your points
clear and
succinct um do we have any speakers
please
tar um yes chairman obviously Council D
has his point of order and councelor
um bit has asked to
speak thank you um councelor Darren
first yeah thank you chairman very much
for for indulging me I I very much
regret that we've Now find ourselves in
rather a sorry
position um I do appreciate the fact
that the um the Democratic uh Alliance
Group uh are are new um but uh they must
be given the opportunity the leader of
that group must be given the opportunity
to select which committees he wishes
those vacant places to go to it is quite
incorrect if the leader of that group
isn't given that
opportunity um I think that there was a
a proposal or there may well be a
proposal that Council picks those
positions uh which would absolutely not
be correct and uh I'm afraid would be
challenged um so uh chairman I I'm just
uh I don't know whether this is in
effect fact in fact what the the leader
is going to propose um but I think we
need to give leader of a legitimate
group the opportunity to nominate who he
wishes to appear uh or or which
committees he wishes uh those two places
to be allocated to thank you very much
indeed thank you um Mr quelt can you
advise on
this yes uh I mean what what Mr Dodson
has said is absolutely right um there
are the the in working out these figures
we as officers were were very much
emphasizing principle D in other words
that of the of of section 15 of the 1989
act namely that um each committee should
as far as possible
reflect um the the political composition
the proportion that each political group
has as against the total membership so
that's what we've been operating on but
we
underplayed principle C namely you've
also got to look at all the all the um
the N the total number of seats
allocated to each group over the whole
Council now when you do that you're left
with the Democratic
Alliance um really being entitled to and
this is applying all the principles now
to two of three committees with one on
each of those two namely licensing
overview and scrutiny and um performance
governance and
audit now because those are equally tied
in relation to which two of the
democratic align should um should sit on
then um it really it isn't really for
the leader of the group to decide that
it really is for Council to decide that
because they're equally tied those three
committees and and so we can't use the
maths we can't use the the statute to
determine that in which case uh Council
itself will need to determine
it okay thank you um I see your hand
councelor Helm I'll come to you after
councelor
Benford he's on the
phone
uh thank you
chair um I'm
questioning the um the first part of
this
recommendation because as a councilor
stamp quite the new leader quite rightly
pointed out that this recommendation
says that the council considers
ratification sorry I'm looking at the
wrong I'm looking at the wrong page page
nine nothing um yes the allocation of
seats on
committees as set out in section 3.6
below be
ratified now that isn't correct is it
because we're now saying the allocation
of seats is not right so I can't see
that we can ratify that but bearing in
mind what Simon quelch has just said um
I'd like to propose that we use the
first two of these um Council
appointments on this table the first one
is performance governance and audit and
the second one is overview and scrutiny
but um I'll second that that's what I
propose um seconded I appreciate what
councelor Durham has said but um Mr quch
seems to
disagree so I put that to Council vote
chairman okay thank you I've I've noted
that proposal and seconded just like to
go to councelor helm and then I'll come
to you
leader thank you very much Mr chairman
um if you'll forgive me I have chosen
the two committees our two members
should go on and that is PGA and
overview and scrutiny if that's all
right and if you want the names for that
committee I'll give
them thank you thank you um
leader uh thank you chairman no I
totally agree with uh Mr quelch on this
it is for the council to decide and I uh
Council banford has uh made the
recommendation but I would also like to
make a
recommendation um that I propose that
the two additional U allocation for the
Democratic Alliance Group are allocated
to overview in scrutiny and investigator
and disciplinary panel committees and I
will have that seconded if somebody will
in second second that please the council
has to Second
seconded well we already have a proposal
which has been seconded um by first of
all uh proposed by councilor Bamford
that uh the uh the PGA and overview and
scrutiny are the Committees and that was
seconded by um councelor chener
councelor chener you've got a point of
order well yes thank you thank you
chairman very much um I heard what Mr
queler said but equally I did hear what
um councelor Durham said and I've
obviously seconded councel banford um
because that seemed perfectly reasonable
to me and I've also heard from the
Democratic Alliance leader who has um
obviously um said what he'd want and I I
I do think um that's why I seconded
councelor banford because I don't think
it is a matter for Council I'm not quite
sure having heard that what element of
the Constitution covers that point
regarding this matter ordinarily had the
correct uh percentages being applied
then the leader of the democratic
Alliance would have had the right to
give his name those names like your uh
The Independents and the conservatives
house so councelor Durham is correct in
that he's lost that opportunity so
tonight that opportunity is being given
and councelor bamford's made the
proposals and you've heard what the
Democratic Alliance leader has said
which happens to be the same so that's
why I seconded it but I can't see in the
Constitution where by this issue um that
we can apply the vote to council from
what I consider the the standing orders
and the Constitution um that element
isn't covered so I do think we have to
go with the proposal councilor bamford's
placed chairman I think it's if you
allow me I think we've had legal advice
which we've heard so many times at these
Council meetings and I would urge people
to cons uh members to actually consider
the the advice that has been given by uh
Mr quelch uh it is a decision by Council
uh and um I totally don't agree and I
think we should have a vote on Council
bamfords and if it fails then I'd like
my proposal made uh accepted please and
voted on and I'd like a recorded vote
please
chairman very well uh that's uh second
the recorded vote the recorded vote all
right okay uh that's what we'll we'll go
for the first proposal uh which is
Council of banford can you just remind
us councilor banford uh PG and a and ow
Andis that that's correct chairman and
um I want a recorded vote on this one
please and you're saying that that
should go to the Democratic Alliance
those too yes I'm proposing that that uh
the seat on PGA and the seat on overview
and scrutiny goes to the Democratic
Alliance as per the leader of that
group's
request okay and I want that minuted
please chairman exactly as I've said it
okay chairman do we do we sorry to
interrupt you again but do we need to
speak to Simon quelch again so he can
make it clear to all members which often
happens at these meetings he does repeat
himself to make it clear for any members
if they have any issues I think it's
important this because the advice that
has been given is from US legal
specialist thank you chair yes could I
just ask you to bring some clarity to
this Mr quch please um I think I don't
know if I can bring any more clarity it
is quite complex um I accept that the
political balance Provisions are very
complex these three
committees um licensing overview and
scrutiny um and PG a um are all 10
person committees and that's the reason
that de Democratic Alliance um only have
one person on each of those and that's
why when you apply the political balance
Provisions they are you could say
equally unrepresented on each of those
three and that's why Mr Dodson who under
the Constitution can have the final
ruling in relation to allocations is not
doing so because the maths
that um one has to apply means that
those three committees equally apply so
that's why it would have to be a
decision of council and not the decision
of the leader of the of that particular
group that's all I can say I don't think
I can make it any
clearer um can't think of a way of
making it
clearer okay thank you very much
councelor banford I will allow you to
come back I've got four other speakers
thank you chairman because I just wanted
to clarify because I believe the the
leader has put forward a committee that
has not been mentioned by Simon quelch I
believe she put forward o uh was it
overview and scrutiny and investigating
and disciplinary and not the not the
three not one of the three that Mr Quil
just mentioned so I don't think her
recommenda her proposal is actually
valid according to the legal advice
well I think what we'll do is we'll take
we'll take the uh the first proposal and
if that fails we'll come back to Mr quch
to see if that advice uh is legal or not
but meanwhile uh I've I've got four
other speakers before I go to the vote
councelor
chenna no I've said my piece thank you
thank you very much councelor
Swain
yes thank you um chairman um it's not
surprising that this sort of um
eventuality isn't actually covered
specifically in the
Constitution um but what we have here is
um uh should we say the list of the um
possible vacancies for the two D members
and from what Mr quch has said um it is
for the council to decide
um the alter I I would um Advocate a
different approach and that is to take
them one by one to take a proposition
for um putting um um a d member on PGA
yes or no and then and deal with it that
way um individually by the the four
committees that are um posses for D
member um uh I don't think you know it
would be more simple and easier to do it
that way rather than trying to come up
with a a some combination and then vote
on all sorts of combinations of
twos I think I think Mr quil's advice is
quite clear
really okay thank you councelor
councelor
lagen yeah thank you chairman um I just
uh just wanted to sort of reiterate um
from listening to the debate um that um
Simon has is a very experienced legal
specialist and for many many years has
served the council well um so I
appreciate his advice and I believe that
we should take his advice as we've done
in the past um and uh follow it through
and I support the leader's
recommendation thank
you thank you very much and councelor
Nan Deputy leader thank you very much
chair um so yes um just to be clear um
is councelor Bamford councelor stamp the
leader and councelor Helm are they all
saying overview and scrutiny as one of
those yes I think they are yes so why
are we even debating overview and
scrutin why don't we just uh vote on the
uh the other the other the other uh
group the other seat well I think that
um I think councilor Swain was
suggesting that we do do those
individually um do you think that's a
good idea Mr qu well chairman you
actually have uh um you actually have a
proposal that's been seconded on the
table from um councelor um bford so that
really has to be disposed of first of
all all right okay fair enough chair I
was just uh trying to be pragmatic
really but uh if that's the way we've
got to do it then fine
okay so we we have the proposal by
councelor panford for pgna and overview
and scrutiny this was seconded by
councelor uh Chana uh a recorded vote
has been requested and seconded so Torah
can we take the vote on that
please yes chairman of course um so
voting for allocating uh performance
governance and audit and over and
scrutiny committee to the Democratic
Alliance Group
uh starting with Council banford if you
can indicate for against or abstain
please for thank you very much councelor
Bassinger against you councelor miss
Bal for thank you councelor Brian bill
against thank you councelor Bell against
thank you councelor
Boyce
against Miss sorry sorry for sorry sorry
for thank you for Council voice council
Mrs
CH uh T I'm for because the leader of
the democratic Alliance has indicated
what he where he wants to place his
members and I that's why I've seconded
the leader's proposal as well so thank
you thank you uh councilor
Durham four and we'll see what the local
government Ombudsman has to say thank
you thank you councelor Edwards again
against thank you councelor Fleming for
thank you coun
Fluker uh first of all I concur with
what councelor darham said and we should
be very very very careful here
for thank you counc heard
against councelor Helm
for you councelor
Hull
four councelor
Jarvis
against you councelor
keys
for you councelor
lagin against you councelor
maze
against
for
Morris
against you councelor none against thank
you councelor
shessy
against Council Sidle against thank
you
against councelor stamp against thank
you councelor SS against you councelor
Swain
against counc Mrs
Thompson for councelor Miss
White for the chairman the results of
that vote are 13 for and 16 against
thank you
then that uh that fails so uh leader can
you remind us of your proposal I can but
I need some help because it Miss uh
Council banford said I'd said the wrong
um committee can I have Clarity because
then the list that I've got uh Mr Dodson
I've got Council appointments on
pgna uh OV and scrutiny investigating
and disciplinary panel pool and
Licensing are they the four that we're
talking about please because I will have
to amend my proposal if I'm Incorrect
and I apologize to the council but
that's what I've got written down thank
you so you're saying overview and
scrutiny and investigation and
disciplinary panel Paul and this is
going to be uh determined by the
council uh yes but I've been told I'm
incorrect chairman so I I need
clarification if I'm incorrect I need to
know if it is licensing in or
investigator and disciplinary panel pool
thank
you through you chair if I can answer
that the the four committees that that
need to be appointed to that where there
are spare seats rpga licensing overview
and scrutiny and
um
ID and but I think what um Mr quch said
was the the the three PGA licensing an
overview and scrutiny are all 10 person
um committees and as such th those were
the ones that he pointed out should be
um favored in in terms of
appointing these two two seats to either
of any of those
three okay thank you chairman I know CC
banford uh wanting to come in here uh
but am I allowed to withdraw my
Amendment if is seconded seconded by a
counselor and propose the new one to
include
licensing right um I'll I'll go to
councelor banford first because she's
raised a point of order I think that's
that the proposal has been made and
seconded is that
correct that's correct
chairman so are you saying that we are
you saying that we should go with that
whether it's right or
wrong no you don't have to have
withdrawn it you're allowed to withdraw
the point I've made is that the proposal
has been made and seconded so we should
vote on
it I think somebody can withdraw it
surely I think I think I think we are
looking at an amendment here are we
not Mr quelt can you help us yeah um yes
I think I can I I I
had I had understood that um um actually
that the leader hadn't put her proposal
um after the first proposal of councelor
Bamford fell I didn't think she'd
actually put it so you can only put a uh
you can only put a a second proposal
after disposal of the first so in so far
as
um the leader was talking about
investigatory and iary panel um that
wasn't a proposal in itself because you
only had one proposal on its table
unless I've I've not heard that there
was a proposal put after the first
proposal
fell and I didn't so that that means it
that there isn't a second proposal yet
on the table to be amended all right can
I go to councelor Thompson who has a
point of
order um thank you chairman through you
I may need Mr qu's some help on this I'm
frantically trying to find some
information on the investigation and
disciplinary panel but I don't believe
it sits in its entirety unlike a
committee I think it's a it's a so many
out of rather like a licensing
subcommittee but if I could ask for some
help on that through you please chairman
can I ask what your point of order
is
um well it was actually point to
clarification that's what I'm trying to
find out because if it's if it's not a
normal Committee of the council and not
only part of it sits at any one time
then we shouldn't be including
it if I'm right and I don't know if I'm
right which is why I'm asking for your
help please
chairman
SC I think whatever the answer on that
question is the point is this that it
has to be according to the my
understanding of the political balance
Provisions it has to be where it's
called principal D and it's where there
is a more under representation by the
Democratic Alliance and that's where
there is a tie on just those three
bigger committees licensing overview uh
and scrutiny and PGA so it has to be
according to my understanding those
three committees now the the other
commit the other committee is is much
smaller and that's why there isn't an
under representation and therefore the
principal D requires that it has to be
one of these
three that I've
mentioned I say because they're main
committees okay thank you ch ch chair
can I come in and make a proper proposal
now please yes please yeah please I
would like to propose that the two
additional allocations for the
Democratic Alliance Group are all at to
overview and scrutiny committee and the
licensing committee chairman and can I
ask for a second please so I will second
that leader and Mr
chairman thank you so uh do any other
members want to add anything before I go
to a
vote right in that case uh can we agree
that by Ascent or does anybody request
we have a recorded vote please a
recorded vote is that seconded I'll
second that thank you okay Tara a
recorded vote please this is uh uh to uh
allow the two
places um overview and scrutiny and
Licensing should we take those together
or can we split
them together
please that's the proposal then that
they are
together okay chairman may I move an
amendment chairman on
that go ahead councilor chairman
you're muted at the
moment um well this is I've got a
problem then I think um chairman um I've
got my mic open so okay I'll I'll just
have to wait I hear you now I hear you
now oh you've gone off
again councelor Boyce you wish to
speak yes chairman thank you um the
statute says that they need to be
ordinary members of the council uh sorry
ordinary Committees of the council um
and that implies um that they're ongoing
committees and not um one that might not
um sit so in my view the idea of pulled
committees such as I andd um uh are not
um uh shouldn't be in the equation um
was
was a question um for you chairman um
was the licensing committee um one of
the Committees that was first put in
with the um 64 or has it been added
Since U Mr Johnson are you able to
answer
that who's Mr Johnson Mr
doson yes that was included chairman was
included thank you chairman uh so uh
then if uh Mr qu would agree with me
then it is appropriate for licensing and
PN um overview and scrutiny to be um uh
uh considered although personally I if
ID have been involved I would have um
picked another solution however um I'm
I'm happy with with that okay thank you
so we have the uh proposal uh for the
places overview and scrutiny and
Licensing it's been duly seconded we've
had a recorded vote which has been
seconded uh so we'll now go to the
recorded vote thank you
Tara thank you chairman and members if
you could indicate for against or
abstain and this is for the two
additional allocations for the
Democratic Alliance Group allocated to
OB scrutiny and Licensing committee
thank you very much St this is the
proposal by Council of stamp is that
correct yes chairman right thank you
stting the council bord please thank you
Tara this is a difficult one because um
I don't disagree with this but because I
actually proposed uh PGA before and that
was turned down um I've got to go
against it but I do agree that they
should have the two committee places so
this is difficult thank you very much
councilor Bassinger
please for thank you thank you councelor
Miss
against C Brian Bill
four
four councelor Boyce for thank you
councelor Mrs
CH against because uh I'm following
Council banford as I supported her thank
you very much councelor
Dar oh thank you uh Miss bird on the
basis that I believe that the leader of
the group should have the choice uh I'm
regrettably voting against and this will
be referred to the local government
Ombudsman for a report thank
you and councelor
Edwards for thank you councelor Fleming
against thank you councelor
fuka against and I think you should
listen to what councelor d Miss
saying heard I will abstain thank
you i' just like to say that that the
chairman said about working people
together and he's working against us at
the moment and I'm against thank you
Andy Andy poopes the deputy leader
please point of order please point of
order can we stop having interruptions
please thank you carry on can we carry
on with the vote please and and no um
additional comments thank you councilor
Hull you're
next against thank you
Jarvis for thank you councelor Keys
against thank you councelor
lagum it's a shame that we're not in the
chamber so I could give you a suite to
remove the bad taste uh definitely four
please thank you councelor Ma four thank
you councelor
moley against thank you councelor
Morris definitely
four coun
none coun
sha
four councelor Sidle four thank you
councelor schemes
four four
Swain councelor Mrs
Thompson against and councelor Miss
White although I support members of The
Alliance being on these committees I
think the proposal is flawed therefore
it's reason I against point we just have
for or against
please I I ended it with against thank
you thank you chairman the results of
that are 16 for
16 for 12 against and one abstention
thank you
chairman in that case that uh is uh has
passed um Mr Dodson do you have the
next part of this agender item
15 think we've got one one place left to
find have
we
soorry chairman there are two places um
left to appoint too um councelor Helm
would now need to appoint to nominate
his um members to those two positions
that have been allocated to the um
Democratic Alliance and then the the two
remaining places need to be appointed by
by Council which I think would now be
the p position on PGA and the position
on
IDP thank you very much so um councelor
Helm do you have two names one for
overview and scrutiny and one for
licensing overie and scrutiny myself C
Mr chairman and Bob boy for licensing
please I will second that Mr
chairman thank you um
um can that as we have voted on that I
don't think we have to go around gain
and vote on that Tara do
we
chairman I think that can just probably
be added because we've obviously be
voting on committees at a later stage
yes I think so I think so so the next uh
the next part then is um sorry um
chairman sorry to to intervene I believe
there's an issue with councelor Helm
sitting on PGA and overview and
scrutiny
sorry do you have another name Council
Helm uh Council boce for overview and
scrutiny and uh councelor Boyce for the
other one please is yeah councelor Boyce
for both
please councelor voice for both yes
pleas chairman I don't if if councelor
Helm can't be on PGA and overview and
scrutiny um I don't think I can either
can
I chairman you can't sit on a program
committee overview and
scrutiny that's correct do you have
another name councelor
hel uh councelor
duck he's already on over you and
scrutin which one do you want one four
now both of them or one of them well you
can't sit on um SNR or pgna and overview
and scrutiny because the uh the council
decreed
that
uh councelor boys for licensing
please and as neither my myself or Bob
can go on over you and scrutiny we're
we've been scuppered by you thank
you so are you saying you're not going
to put a name forward we can't put one
according to
you um in that case um would that be um
awarded by Council
b b but hang on those new rules don't
come in until after excuse me point of
order should we are not in a debate Mr
chairman can I ask can I seek advice
from Mr quelch
please uh point of order chairman point
of order please it is for you as
chairman to say if someone can speak or
not we are actually discussing a very
serious matter here because a proposal
went forward that actually was was not
valid because it applied to people not
being able to sit because the Democratic
Alliance already said who they wanted um
just put places and now they're being
denied that through the proposal that
appears to be given and of course with
the selection they've had they're now
putting in this invidious position it's
not fair chairman they have a right to
two seats and the names they
want well I think that we have already
agreed we've already agreed that it is
um it is um overview and scrutiny and
Licensing we've already agreed that um
I've got a couple of um speakers here
but I'd like to go to Mr quelch first
because I think we're getting in a bit
of a soup here Mr quelch what's your
advice
chairman my point was yes that was
agreed but they're now being told that
the names can't Mr Dodson came in and
said because of the nominations
previously which are on the order paper
tonight as result of that proposal that
they now find themselves in invidious
position of saying they can't be on Oban
scrutiny I'm sorry it can't be on PGA or
whatever because there of over scrutiny
coming in so what I'm saying is overan
scrutiny was put forward for them when
actually they've got some nominations on
to the PGA if you look at the order
paper I think I'm seeing that correct uh
we've got councelor Helm on performance
governance and audit and counselor Boyce
on strategy and resources so the very
fact of putting for over in scrutiny to
say was the committee um and they've
already got councelor duon they're styed
as councelor ham has pointed
out Mr qu can you
assist
um difficult unless unless councelor
Helm is able to move completely around
everybody because I see that councelor
Helm is on performance and
governance councelor Boyce is on
strategy um and
um councelor duick is on overview and
scrutiny now if there's a way of moving
those three around so that um
[Music]
um there can be two Democratic alliance
members on licensing and overview and
scrutiny well the I think the other
option might be to have um count doick
on both would that be an
option overview and scrutiny
and um
licensing yes there's there's
um well councilor jick is already on
overview and
scrutiny right
okay that's that's why I was wondering
whether councilor Helm could if it's
possible to move people around um I'm
just looking at that now if someone else
can assist me one of the other officers
all right can I go to Mr doson
please I see you've got your hand up Mr
do so sorry that that was from earlier
when when I raised the issue around the
not being able to sit on on both and I
don't think it can be done to be honest
with the with the issue is because there
are four the numbers are based on four
and the allocation um but obviously at
the moment there are only three of the
counselors who are able to do it so it's
not possible to have
um there would always have to be two on
um have to be somebody who's on PGA and
ons for it to to work or or SNR and
ons that is their choice though yeah
councel councelor Ma you've got your
hand up uh yeah Mr chairman um this is
their choice um they do have options
available to them and had they actually
done what um the independence did and
put their lists in on time um we would
not be in this moddle thank you Mr
chairman all right thanks although we
are in this model now um councelor uh
Morris first and then councelor
Jarvis thank you chairman um due to his
constant interruptions I would like to
put forward a proposal that councilor
fluka no longer be heard thank
you well I I think that is I think that
is for the chairman to do councelor
Morris I'm I'm grateful for for your
thoughts at the moment um councelor
Jarvis thank you chairman um I'm not
sure if this is the right opportunity um
if not I'm happy to defer but uh uh I'm
obviously a nonaligned conservative I'm
Keen to serve on the PGA committee um
I've obviously been on it since its
formation as its Vice chair and been
involved in lots of aspects of
negotiation our relevant professional
qualifications in finance and governance
and I'd like to continue to serve on it
if that's at all possible and I'd just
like to make that appeal across the
chamber to all uh to to all counselors I
am interested in serving on PGA um for
the benefit of the council and for the
benefit of the people of molden thank
you
chairman um chairman if I if I may um
yes please this may not please councelor
Jarvis but I think the only way it might
work and maybe Mr Dodson would have a
look at this as well is actually if
um Democratic Alliance actually did have
PGA and and and Licensing I think it's
the overview and scrutiny one that's the
problem um so I think if if if say
correct um I think that would actually
work yeah and if that is the only
constitutional way it can work because
of the Constitution because of the
change in the Constitution recently
about this separation of powers then in
fact Democratic Alliance would actually
have to
have um they would actually have to have
licensing and
PGA which I think is what they was that
what that want what they wanted um or
almost what they wanted all right I've
got thank you thank you Mr CR I've got
four speakers councelor Sidle
first thank you chairman uh in terms of
this we we've taken a vote we've had a
motion which is passed uh that has been
agreed by the council the con the terms
of reference as uh Mr qu has just stated
says that uh that people who are on PGA
and SNR cannot sit on overview and scy
it's not nothing to do with fairness
it's just to do with the constitution of
the council so we've taken a vote those
are the positions and we need to move on
chairman if I may speak again um the if
if you permit me to speak yes go ahead
Mr C um chairman
um I I hear what councelor Sidle says
and the vote has been taken but now we
realize looking at the Fig looking at
the situation again that that cannot
constitutionally be right and because
the legislation requires that the
Democratic Alliance do have the two
seats to comply with the principles that
means the only two committees I can see
that they could have are PGA and
Licensing can I come back
please yes councilor Sid thank you
chairman uh yes that they they have the
allocation uh the situation that the PJ
is in at the moment is that one of their
counselors
is unable to sit on committees so the
council has been constitutional in terms
of the allocation it is unfortunate that
one of their counselors at the moment is
under a sanction so therefore that
person is unable to sit on any
committees and that is the reason why
the Democratic Alliance are in the
position that they are it has got
nothing to do with the constitution of
the council one of their counselors is
has a sanction that they cannot sit on
on a
committee okay I'm just going to go to
um councelor Thompson who has a point of
order thank you chairman it is not
reasonable that Council should make a
decision that forces a group not to be
able to take up its full allocation of
places it is simply not reasonable um we
we know we know what this is all about I
hear what councilor Sidle is saying but
a suggestion has being made for
something that it is simply not possible
to do so um I do not see chairman how
you can allow this to happen but thank
you CH chair sorry chairman could I
could I um say something
please yes I'd like to move on from this
really well I've I've it's been ra there
is there is a way that that it could
work um which would be if if either
councelor Helm doubled up on PGA and
strategy and resources or councelor
Boyce did that would free the other
member to sit on overview and
scrutiny counselor um counselor oh what
do we got here point of ORD first of all
um is it councelor Durham has got a
point of
order yeah thank you chairman I know you
want to move on and and I'm sure you're
now going to use your power as chairman
to do so chairman you've just had a
perfectly reasonable legal opinion from
uh uh from the monitoring officer
previously in this meeting other members
have said that we should be following
his legal uh opinion we can't pick and
choose what legal opinion of his uh to
to follow you are perfectly at Liberty
as the chairman to make a ruling Mr
quelch has said that the way out out of
this is to provide a position on pgna
and uh on licensing and hence the
problem is solved um I sincerely hope
that uh you R you make that ruling ases
your ability as I said let's not pick
and choose what legal um opinions we
take this evening because we're just
going to get ourselves in a pickle and
the Ombudsman will sit and watch this
tape and absolutely love every minute of
it thank
you thank you um there one yes leader oh
sorry sorry I'll come back I think it's
it's is it councelor nun before me
chairman well councelor Swain has a
point of order sorry
none if you could be concise please
councelor SW certainly chairman and that
is given the the sanctions that um
councilor Fluker is under um does he
come into the calculation of um
political balance as far as committees
are
concerned well I believe yes I believe
that he does the fact that he can't sit
on the Committees he's still part of
that uh still part of that group I would
say um councelor nun no I'm okay thank
you
chairman I'm GNA bring this to a close
very shortly I'll just go to councelor
chenna I think I would like I as to
speak first didn't I chairman I have got
five people waiting to speak just to
advise you I've been waiting quite a
while chairman yeah I will take
councelor Cher first thank you very much
chairman with no disrespect to the vice
chairman of the council councilor ma
councilor ma made a point that it's down
to the fault of the democratic Alliance
for not getting their list in on time
can I just remind members the leader
said quite clearly that everyone needed
to be aware of this situation which blew
up late this afternoon afternoon and
therefore as we can see on the order
papers the leader of the democratic
Alliance had submitted those names that
he believed he should submit and asked
to submit he was in a meeting I believe
with the other leaders names came
forward and we can see them on our order
paper what has happened is the leader of
the democratic Alliance finds himself in
the position tonight as a result of an
issue that blew up this afternoon in
this position and the council finds
itself in its position so have to say I
resent comments being made um with all
due respect to the vice chairman that
the leader of the democratic Alliance
should have got his list in on time I
think that's very unfair statement
because that is not the issue the issue
is what has blown up this afternoon and
he now causing this problem in this
chamber chairman and I would like that
minuted
please right thank you very much so um
councelor Helm can I uh can I I just ask
you for just to stand by I'll go go on
leader I'll go with you first thank you
I think we're all missing Mr Dodson came
up with the actual um to be able to
solve the puzzle why is nobody listening
to Mr Dodson yes I was just about to put
that to M to councelor helm because he's
not the legal
officer um councelor Helm um chairman
can I just ask we were told when we did
the briefings here not for members to
shout out and the previous chairman was
really adamant councelor chn that we
were not going to be shouting out we are
having so much shouting out it's
unbelievable thank you
chair yes can I call for um some
politeness please within this so are you
there councelor Helm yes I am councelor
herd there is there is a suggestion to
that you would go on to strategy
resources and pgna and that would free
up your other member for overview and
scrutiny
okay is that acceptable to you that's
acceptable to me
yes Mr quelch is that uh is that legal
sure it
is I there Mr
CR is m is the leader of the democratic
Alliance saying that councelor Boyce
would come off strategy and resources
that he would go onto that yeah and then
that councelor Boyce would uh go on to
overview and
scrutiny yes that that's that that's
constitutional yes right then I think
that that's that's what we should uh
that's what we should go for and then
that that meets the criteria I believe
thank you very much Mr
chairman right do any other members have
anything to say on that chairman I've
got councelor Boyce councelor Ma and
councilor B wanting to speak okay I'll
go councelor
Boyce um thank you chairman actually Mrs
Channer said um most of what I intended
to say um uh councelor ma and to a
certain extent councelor Sid were
grossly unfair um to to councelor helm
um he on the meeting that the leaders
had was given what is now incorrect
information that is why we're in this
position thank
you thank you very much councelor
Ma um I I withdraw my question as it's
already been answered thank you very
much councelor
Bell thank you um Mr chairman I will
keep this brief a motion has been passed
um we have been told of a way how we can
how we can meet the requirements of that
by um by Mr Dodson so any reference to
uh not following legal advice is
irrelevant because uh we are and really
threatening us with the Ombudsman really
I suggest we move on thank
you yeah okay I agree with that so um
we'll we'll take that um to the
vote uh in that case um and I think that
um Tara if I've got this right this is
uh councelor hel to go on uh strategy
and resources and pgna and councelor
doick onto overview and scrutiny is that
correct uh yes chairman that is correct
um I just had a quer about what's
happening about licensing because that
was one of the ones that was moved to
them just not clear thank you thank you
sorry sorry chairman it isn't counc Helm
on PGA already looking at it the order
paper I've
got can you help me there Mr Dodson I
thought it was doubling up I thought Mr
quelch's
meaning councilor Boyce might double up
onto PGA so the two Democratic Alliance
have that seat and then that frees up
then there'll be councelor Boyce on
strategy and resources and then that
would free up I believe o scrutiny and
Licensing for councelor duick maybe I've
misinterpreted but I think the idea was
the one member because straty and
resources can't take another on my order
paper can't take another position
Council of voice has already been deemed
by that with the names the leader of the
democratic Alliance has given you I'm
thinking there's meant to be doubling up
from what Mr Dodson said on PGA with a
number Democratic Alliance
seat and then councilor duick would be
over scrutiny and
Licensing so chair with your your
permission I think what I suggested was
that if councilor Helm sat on both
strategy and resources and performance
governance and audit it frees up Council
Boyce to take the extra position on
overview and
scrutiny um and
then they can add also add another
counselor to to licensing because there
are no limits on sitting on that and
another committee thank
you so uh have we Sorry have we got
somebody for
licensing
Mr
doson sorry that that that's for
councelor Helm to to
confirm right I I understand that we're
only looking for for two places for the
D aren't
we councilor Ben
we need to follow legal
advice um thank you chairman I'm I'm
totally confused now and I'm sure most
of us are as what on Earth we are being
asked to do here so I think someone
needs to clarify as I understood it my
regional
proposal um was the one that we could
have gone with but now I'm thinking that
it's PGA and Licensing that we're
talking about now so I I just
confused yes I I have to say that I
think it is becoming very confusing um
I'm going to go back to um the report uh
Mr Dodson can we uh can we see this
report um because I think it is becoming
rather foggy as to who's who is going
where and uh those people who are
putting up for it so can you
clarify
okay we we started with four four spaces
and I confirmed via the
um the the under section c two of those
had to go to um the Democratic Alliance
it was my understanding that on the
second
um
um option that was put forward that it
was agreed that those two would be for
overview and scrutiny and license
in so councelor Helm then subsequently
confirmed that that he would go on to
strategy and resources and PGA which
would then free up Council AB boy to
take the additional space on overview
and
scrutiny so then Council Helm needs to
appoint somebody to do to take the
additional seat in
licensing that leaves an additional seat
on PGA to be allocated by Council and an
additional seat on the IDP to to be
appointed by Council once those are
appointed then Council can um agree all
of those those
positions okay so can we can we see them
up on a screen at
all
um
chair are you going to the table in the
report or the appendix up on the screen
I think we'll take the uh well I don't
think the report is going to help us
terribly much um what we're trying to do
is to fill in fill in the names of who's
going where at the moment I've got
councel Helm on SNR and PGA and
councelor Boyce on
on so I've just made a couple of changes
chairman um in respect of what was
mentioned so councilor hel replacing
Council boce on string resources uh and
Council boce going on to O scrutiny and
I believe it was mentioned that counc
Boyce was gone licensing as well and
that then takes out the one space for
licensing and the one space for overvie
scrutiny right okay um so Mr quelch are
we legal on that I think we are that
correctly from Council H well chairman I
propose actually that we go with C what
Mr quch said and he said it should be
PGA and I think we need to take that
legal advice that is what Mr qu's advice
was and it could be PGA and Licensing
all right um
leader um can sign Mr quelch say whether
it's legal advice or not I mean I think
we've actually come to a solution now
with the help of Mr Dodson uh and I
think all it needs is ratifying or
agreed from the Democratic Alliance
leader uh which is uh Mr helm councelor
Helm and then we can move on I don't see
that an issue here I think the problem
has been solved and I don't believe
there is a a legality issue here maybe
and that's all I'm going to say thank
you chairman yeah I think I think that's
right can you just confirm that
everything we've done has been legal the
point is that actually does have to be
councelor Helm's decision here yes in
this respect I mean he he has
already uh what what Mr Dodson suggested
works but that depends on whether
councelor Helm is happy with that um if
he's not happy with it if he's not happy
with it because those are his selections
as group leader if he's not happy then
it would have to be um he would have to
allocate to licensing and PGA so it
really is in the hands of council Helm
well I think he I think he did agree
these could you confirm that you're
happy with that Helm no who said that
hel I'm asking speaking for Council Helm
I think that's a bit disrespectful as we
said earlier on and I know I'm doing
exactly is I'm a hypocrite can we stop
buttoning and just get the business done
yes counselor Helm can I um ask you if
you're happy with those arrangements I'm
not happy but if we carry on like this
we'll be going on all night so I'll
accept it okay right you'll accept it
okay um in that case that's what we'll
do we'll go for the go for uh agreement
on
that do we need to take a vote on that
Tara or can we do no no because those
then fit th those then go in those are
councelor Helm's choices yes they they
now go into the appendix with all the
names right and at that point you
vote right and that case then we will go
to we will go to the vote uh and members
can can uh decide whether they are for
or against this proposal chairman
there's still the also the two floating
seats left to be
decided the appendix needs to be also
have those two names fitted in as well
which is again Council will need to
nominate those right so this will be the
investiga and disciplinary panel pool
and for and Li and Licensing is that
correct
pgna pgna and investigating and
disciplinary panel
Paul what are the other two seats Mr Mr
Dodson
it's it is PGA and the investigating and
disciplinary panel pool those are the
other two that Council needs to Al um
nominate to right nominate kle Jarvis um
chairman I think you'll find I've put a
a thing in the bar when you're
ready yes leader go ahead uh yes thank
you chair and i' I'd like to thank um
the other leader of the democratic party
um councelor Helm for assisting us to
move that on I think that is absolutely
excellent so thank you very much um I
would now like to propose that the
council member M that is going to be
allocated on
pgna is counselor Carl Jarvis and I also
would like to nominate councelor Kyle
Jarvis on the I and D panel please chair
and can I have any seconders please
excellent un seconded on both and I'd
like a recorded vote if that's agreeable
to if I can get that seconded please
coun chairman Council Bell thank you so
so uh we now have all of those places
I'm very pleased to say uh and we'll now
go to the vote either for or against
those thank you thank you T chair
chairman I believe we can put another
nomination in can we
not if there are some other if there are
other nominations yes although this one
has been uh proposed and seconded but I
will take other nominations our other
nomination for PGA is Sue
White and for for the indd panel it is
Clive
moley okay I'd like a recorded vote
please and I'm happy to Second both of
those
chairman okay that's fine so we'll go
with
um uh the councelor helm and the
leaders uh proposal for the time being
and we have a recorded vote on that
please
Tara sorry chairman I'm just a bit
confused um Can can you just confirm so
are we voting on The Proposal from
councilor Helm first and then going to
deal with the leaders Vote or are you
doing it all all together yes we'll deal
we'll deal with councelor Helm's um
agreement uh as per the as per the
schedule uh and then we can take um uh
the leader's
proposal for Council of Jarvis uh to be
on PGA and investigation disciplinary
so this is a recorded vote in respect of
the nominations that Council Helm has
given us yes okay chairman thank you you
could indicate for abstain for against
or abstain please starting with
councelor bford
please these are the nominations from
appointment
sorry these are these are nominations
that have been agreed by Council
H uh we're voting on
what sorry I'm totally confused what
we're voting on now why are we voting on
this so could we just have the schedule
up again please
T we shouldn't be voting on this
chairman sorry chairman I I can I um add
I think um Council bamford's right I
don't think there needs to be a vote on
this because they were the positions
were agreed and then they were nominated
to by councilor Helm it's just the
remaining in two positions on the one on
performance governance and audit and the
the one on um IDP which need to be voted
upon right okay so so we've agreed the
places uh for for Council Helm so the
next thing to vote for is the proposal
by the leader for councelor Jarvis uh to
be a member of the pgna and
investigation and disciplinary
committee yes yes
startford
please counc against sorry against thank
you councilor
Bassinger
for Miss
Beal
against councelor Brian Beal
for councelor bell four thank you
councelor bis against thank councel Mrs
chener against this is not fair because
it's not what the Democratic um Alliance
leader
wanted on move on move on councelor
Doren against thank you councelor
Edwards for thank you councelor Mrs
Fleming against thank you councelor
Fluker against thank you councelor Miss
councelor herd for thank you councelor
Helm against thank thank you councel
Hull against councelor
Jarvis
for
Keys against councelor
lagen for please Tara thank you
councelor Ma for thank you councelor
moley against thank you councelor
Morris wholeheartedly four thank you
councelor none
fourk you counc
shessy
four four councelor schemes four
councelor stamp four coun STS four coun
Swain or councelor Mrs Thompson against
and councelor Miss White against thank
you chairman the results of that are 16
for 13 against and no extensions thank
you
chairman thank you very much that uh
that is carried then uh agenda item 16
is actually an adjournment of the
meeting in order that we canor chairman
sorry I have to interrupt that was the
vote for Council Jarvis on performance
governance and audit we haven't actually
voted for the other proposal and we
haven't agreed the committee membership
yet all right okay so we'll go with the
second proposal which was um by um
councelor banford I believe which was
for um councelor Sue
white chair don't have to do that chair
I think we T Miss bird can you help the
chairman I think I think we're actually
now voting on the indd panel aren't we
my proposal was in two parts first if
that fails then we go to Council of
Bamford but the first one has actually
been o uh approved chairman I hope you
don't mind me help op on that one it's
getting a bit
confusing that's right so it would be um
the leader's proposition for Council
Jaris to go on the investigating
disciplinary panel
pool yes that's so that that is that is
pass yes no we haven't voted on that
chairman we voted on him going on to
Performance governance and audit
committee
right so what is sorry what is the next
proposal for Council Jarvis to go on the
investigating and disciplinary
panel
okay okay can we take the vote for that
please yeah certainly chairman starting
Council banford
please against canc
passinger four thank you councelor Miss
bill
against Brian bill
for councelor bell for coun Boyce
against thank you councelor Mrs
Channer
against thank you councelor
Durham against thank you councelor
Edwards
for
Fleming
against CC
Fluker against you councelor herd for
coun Helm
against
against councelor
Jarvis
Four councelor
Keys
against for thank you councelor
moley against thank you councelor
Morris four you councelor
nun four councelor
sha
four Sidle four thank you councelor
skines four councelor stamp four
councelor SS
four councelor
Swain
four you councel Mrs Thompson against
and councelor Miss White against thank
you chairman so the result of that is 16
for 13 against and no extensions thank
you chairman thank you very much right I
think we now need to approve the
positions as a whole uh and then uh
we'll hold the committee meetings uh to
uh nominate the um appointments panel I
believe yes chairman and just to advise
that Council boy you want to speak in
relation to area planning committees as
he advised
earlier yes chairman I'm going to just
before you start I'm going I'm I know
we've still got a little bit to go
through uh I'm going to propose a
comfort break in a moment but I just
think we wanted to uh I want to clear
this matter first agenda item
15 councilor
boys uh chairman if you can go for a
comfort break I think what I'm going to
say might be best held after after it um
uh
because um all right I shall continue um
agenda item 15 um in relation to the
area committees there's an advisory
there that says that we can do this
because of the
1990 regulations part four paragraph
16a um there's two issues here chairman
that actually is on my reading says that
we can have an area committee that's not
politically balanced providing it
doesn't isn't greater than two fifths of
the area of the um uh District The
Authority or more than two fifths of the
population um of
the um District
um now I believe that that that probably
fils on both parts and what we have
here uh is I
suggest what we actually do is we use
section 17 of the local government and
Housing Act
1989 uh can you or Mr quch confirm
this Mr quch uh
I'm I'm I'm I'm surprised to hear that
because for for years area planning
committee has has always been considered
to be each one less within the
thresholds of political balance not
applying I think this is the first time
this has been
raised um the geography hasn't changed I
suppose it's possible um from last year
to this that the population has changed
I am not aware um I don't know the
population of each um area committee so
um the council has always treated each
of the three area committies as within
the thresholds of political balance not
applying so my question would be what
what has changed in terms of bypassing
or going beyond the threshold in section
16a of the regulations and I'm not aware
of anything um 16a as I read it um
kindly thanks to use applying it to me
um actually says providing that it's not
greater than two fths of the
area and Southeast is certainly larger
than two- fifths of the area okay and
that the two fifths the two fths of the
population and I think probably one or
more areas uh meets that as well and you
quite rightly um say um that this hasn't
Arisen before although I have questioned
it before and I have been referred to
this 1990 part four um does section 17
of the local government and housing acts
apply to our area
committees
um well chairman um is section 17 is
Council Bo talking about the
disapplication
provisions in second section
17 section 17 says that um an authority
can give
consent providing it is unanimous with
no member
dissenting in which in which case
chairman yes that's the disapplication
provisions we use them we use them the
council use them in June if you remember
in relation to Joint standards committee
um the question I I suppose question
really is Chairman
whether whether this two FS geography um
threshold has been passed as I say for
quite a few years I think it's always
been accepted that the area committees
have being within the two fifths so I I
can't answer that I don't know the
geography no can I can I go to council
councel nun next then thank you Mr qu
yes thank very much chairman can I ask
chairman whether any notice has been
given by Council voice to this proposed
change
sorry not given of this proposed change
um sorry uh can you hear me okay yes yes
my question was can I ask please whether
any notice has been given to this
proposed change of disapplication by
councelor
Boyce I've received um um I don't have
to give any uh notice um I'm asking a
simple question does section 17
apply um through the chair um it sounded
like a proposition to me uh and no no no
no no no it's chairman sorry um to
interrupt councelor Nan uh it's not a
proposition um I'm asking a simple
question the the effect of the section
17 is that if any member votes
against um the in this in this case um
giving up political balance in the area
committees they have to then be
politically
balanced it's not a proposition it's
just a a legal fact it's not in our
constitution because it's
statute
and Mr quch has attempted to answer but
he seems to
be well I mustn't say he's evading the
question but he's not answering the
question does section 17
apply uh although to give him his due he
did say he didn't know about what two FS
of the geography of the um the district
is but I can assure him that the um
Southeast area is more than two fths of
the total area of the district
chairman I did actually ask to speak
before councelor nun I asked to speak at
2018 and councelor nun um whilst I
absolutely admire councelor Boyce and he
knows I do um can I ask what the
relevance of this is I thought we were
actually trying to um not protect our
officers but what is the relevance of
asking this question at this moment in
time and I also agree with counselor nun
you know this is a very detailed um
specific of the law and I think a bit of
notice would have been common courtesy
and I'm not being insulted um councelor
boy you know I think the absolute world
of view but can you tell me why you've
actually raised this now are you
proposing that something Chang hang on I
haven't finished yet I haven't finished
yet I didn't interrupt you I I'd like to
know in in the relation of it and and
most probably why you didn't give uh
more notice to um Mr quch thank
you
yes I think I
would chairman I I
I I asked a simple
question um and I'm amazed I don't think
that Mr Crouch is is able to answer that
perhaps he can come back to you when we
are not meeting well no it'll be too too
late
then well perhaps that question should
have been put a little bit earlier
councelor Boyce
chairman with your permission could
could I try and clar if you'll permit me
to just clarify the answer is um that
councelor Boyce is is is seeking is yes
if the threshold um doesn't apply if if
one of the area planning committees is
beyond the two fifths
geographically then yes councelor Boyce
is right section 17 does
apply the political balance Provisions
can be disapplied
if there is no
member um that objects to the
disapplication the question for me
rather
is I don't know the geography
sufficiently of the district um the size
of each area committed to say whether in
fact what was previously thought to be
within the threshold is now over the
threshold I as you say I don't I don't
think that geography um has uh has
changed at all and I and I'm going to
move on uh from this and and that's
something that you'll have to take up
another time well no I'm not prepared to
take it another time I will be voting
against um uh giving up political
balance in the area committees and I
would ask that my vote be recorded
against
it right okay um I think I'm prepared to
adjourn this meeting now uh just for
Comfort break of 10 minutes um and we
will resume uh on agenda item number 16
uh at
8:35 please sorry chairman we still
haven't finished agenda item
15 right voted on the committee sorry
chairman so this is to confirm the
nominations of the appointments board is
it
we need to agree the nominations of the
leaders and the appointment of the
various members to the committees as set
out on the
appendix right okay this doesn't seem to
appear on my on my script
here can you help me Mr
Dodson chairman it's recommendation two
on the report that the member nomination
set out an append a
yes recommendation three which was that
where nominations haven't been received
to appoint those committees so we've
actually combined the two effectively
but we need to agree the the the
nominations okay our members happy to
agree those
nominations in that case we'll take it
to the vote
then sorry chairman can I I can't use
the chat yes Council RS um on the
um strategy and resources committee on
my sheet cancel schemes is not on it and
he should be
sorry what what page are you on appendix
a yes page 13 yeah I see that yes can
coun Edwards Len Sidle stamp and S and
it should include counselor schemes I've
got I've got counselor schemes on my
copy oh by chairman sorry mine's out of
date then sorry thank you all right okay
so uh so members can we go back to the
recommendations that the member
nomination set out in appendix a be
approved agreed agreed agreed chairman
chairman to come in because I I would
like to clarify the significance of what
council of Boyce has raised does that
affect appendix
a and we haven't agreed um the
recommendation one little one on the
order paper
either recommend well I think we've
agreed the allocation of seats on
committees I think that has been
agreed actually vote on that
chairman chairman um I'm sorry chairman
can I just interrup here um you may not
know this or you may but I do suffer
from a complaint and I'm I I do feel
that I might need to have a urgent a
committee uh Break um and we haven't we
haven't finished yet but I don't want to
be denied having the right to vote on
any matters that might come up which
would be the case if I'm not present
chairman have to have done this
publicly sorry I didn't catch the last
part can we just not move to the move to
the votes if if members want chairman if
members want to vote individually on the
recommendations it'll be five minutes
and then there lots of other people
would like a com Comfort break as well
rather than break in the middle of this
I was answering the chairman of the
council's question apologies I've been
spoken over chairman you might not have
heard me I'm just saying I hate to have
had to admit this
publicly yeah here
Penny yes I I I understand that I think
I think what we'll do is uh we'll go for
the comfort break now uh and then we'll
take the vote when we come back uh so
it's 8:30 now we'll have 10 minutes
please
chairman just check with it thank
you we're now live chairman thank you
thank you um welcome back members uh uh
and members of the public um we're still
on agenda item 15 and uh we have the
recommendations uh that are set out on
the report uh on page nine and that is
uh that the allocation of seats on
committees as set out in section
3.6 below be
ratified uh are members agreeable of
that no
chairman then we'll could
I vot we'll go to we'll go to the vote
on that uh and see whether we agree or
not uh so can we is there did somebody
said there was a recorded vote Yes a
recorded vote please that
seconded second
thank you okay Tara if you could
uh
call sorry to interrupt um I think
counselor Keys is not back in yet he
can't get back
in okay uh we'll wait for the it for
that I will try and invite him again
chairman be with
me
than
chairman I'm not quite clear are we
agreeing 3.6 or are we having names
there I think uh I think Miss bird has
got the names I'd like to know the names
because I'm not clear on the
names are we able to put them up Tara
please and I'm not sure where the
proposals were for the names if I'm
honest yes chairman bear with me a
moment thank
you
so members this is appendix one that I
have just amended following the
council's agreement of nominations to
committees so um councelor Jarvis has
been nominated to Performance
governance councelor Helm has swapped
around his nomination on strategy and
resources uh he's added councelor Boyce
to licensing he's added councilor Boyce
to um o scrutiny and then Council Jarvis
has been added to investigating and
disciplinary
panel
thank you very
much we'll now we'll now take the
recorded
vote so chairman we're taking a vote in
relation to recommendation one on the
report or are you are you taking
recorded vote in relation to the
appendix
a we are we we're going to do uh one and
two okay so recommend recomendation one
is that the allocation of seats on the
committees as set out in 3.6 of the
report be ratified and then
recommendation two is that the
nominations set out in appendix a be
approved so members if you could um
indicate uh if you're for against or
abstain when I call your name please um
starting with councelor Bamford please
well I'm sorry Tara but I I did ask the
question as to whether coun Boyce is um
Point affected appendix a so I until I
have that that answer I don't know I'm
I'm going to vote against because I
still haven't had that
clarification on appendix a whether it's
affected by what councelor boy brought
up we didn't get an answer I think we've
sought advice from uh Mr quelch and I'm
I'm gonna go move on with the
vote I'm not in that case chairman I'm
against thank you
thank you very much councelor
Bassinger four thank you councelor Miss
Beal against thank you councelor Brian
Bill counc
b counc Bell just a
moment could I speak please speaking you
called for counselor Miss Beal you never
heard anything then you suddenly
councelor Beal I didn't know if he was
prompting counselor Miss Beal or
myself bill vot against and then I deor
for councelor Brian bill so yourself
pleas yes for thank you very much
councelor
bell four
please thank you council Mrs
chel uh sorry I've got a problem with my
mute button here can you hear me yes we
can hear you okay I have to be against
I'm sorry this I don't think I'm with
all due respect I don't recorded as
against thank you I like that
minuted uh councelor dorham against
thank you councel Edwards for thank you
councelor Mrs Fleming against thank you
coun Fluker it's Ultra vires
against thank you councelor herd for
thank you councelor helm
against thank you councelor
Hull against councelor
Jarvis
for
Keys against thank you for your help
getting me in thank
you councelor lag four please Tara
councelor four thank you very much
couny is now joining against thank you
councelor
Morris four thank you councelor num four
thank you councelor
shaunessy four thank you councelor Sidle
four thank you councelor
sches four counc stamp fourk you
councelor STS
four
Swain counc Mrs
Thompson again sorry button trouble
against and councelor Miss
White against thank you chairman so the
results of that vote is 16 for 13
against and no extensions thank you
thank you that is uh
carried now we'll move on to agenda item
16 uh members we will now uh adjourn the
meeting at 8:47 to allow the following
special meetings of the council
to take place uh we'll be starting with
the performance governance and audit
committee uh I will
now Council banford you've called a
point of
order sorry I spelled it wrong chairman
but um we aren't we going to actually
have some clarification on what um
councilor voice raised about I'm sorry
we've moved on from that and I'm now
with are now on agenda item
16 so that is I will now call for
nominations to Chairman of the
performance governance and audit
committee uh for the remainder of the
municipal year to May
2021 uh any member um M I think uh Mr is
it Mr Dodson or Mr Holmes will call out
the names of the
members that will be me chairman thank
you okay uh so Mr Dodson will call out
the the uh names of the members of the
pgna uh and then I will be calling uh
for um nominations for chair thank you
Mr
doson okay we have councelor herd
councelor nun councelor shaes councelor
stamp councelor stilts councelor Mrs
Channer councelor
councelor
Keys councelor Helm and councelor
Jarvis thank you so I will now call for
nominations to uh to Chairman for the
remainder of the municipal year to May
2021 is there any nominations councelor
nun nominates councelor Janette SS as
chair of PGA I'd like to second that
chairman so that is councilor still uh
nominated by councelor nun
and seconded by councelor stamp are
there any other
nominations uh in the uh if that is the
case uh in the event of no other
nominations I declare that councelor
Janette stil uh is the appointed
chairman of the performance governance
and audit committee and and I now hand
over to her uh as chairman of the
committee thank you Mr chairman thank
you members um I now would like to call
for nominations of the vice chair of
pgna and from the chair I would nominate
councelor
Jarvis I'd second that
please okay that's do I have any other
any other nominations
I
no other nominations then I would uh
propose that councelor Jarvis is the
vice chair of pgna thank you members I
will close the meeting of
pgna thank you so the meeting is closed
at
8:50 um we will now uh have a meeting a
special meeting of the strategy and
resources committee um Mr dwon please
could you please call out the names of
those members
yes thank you it's councelor Edwards
councelor Lagan councelor siddle
councelor skines councelor stamp
councelor Swain councelor Mrs Channer
councelor Durham councelor Mrs Thompson
councelor Miss White and councelor
Helm thank you very much uh I now call
for nominations for uh chairman of of PG
and a uh for the remainder of the
municipal year to May
2021 um i' propose councelor sidor um
chairman chairman I think you'll find
that uh I was nominated in the chat bar
please I don't have a problem but I
would like to nominate councilor Sid
thank you okay thank you very much um
thank you
councelor thank you lader uh is that
seconded by you councelor Swain yes
thank you it is thank you are there any
other
nominations uh in the absence of any
other nomination I declare councelor
Richard Sidle as chairman of uh strategy
and resources and I now hand over the
meeting to him thank you chairman uh I
would now like to appoint a vice
chairman of the committee for the
remainder of the municipal year to May
2021 and from the P chair I would like
to propose councelor Christopher
Swain I'll second that please
chairman are there any other
nominations
no okay thank you very much chairman I
now hand back to
you thank you very much uh so that is
councilor Swain uh has been elected as
the vice chair of that
committee uh we now move forward to the
overview and scrutiny
committee uh Mr Dodson can you please
call out uh those members for overview
and
scrutiny yes thank you chairman we have
councelor
Bassinger councelor B councelor Bell
councelor Mae councelor Morris councelor
Bamford councelor Keys councelor
moley councelor duick and councelor
Boyce thank you very much I'm sorry
members I I did mean to say to you when
uh when your name is called uh can you
please uh open your videos um and your
mics uh in order that the members of the
public can see uh can see you so I now
called for nominations uh for
chairman uh of the
um and scrutiny and scrutiny sorry I now
call for nominations uh for chairman for
the overview and scrutiny committee for
the for the remainder of the municipal
year to May
2021 um councilor ma would like to
propose councelor Vanessa
Bell councilor ke would like to PR elain
banford
and I would like to Second uh Vanessa
Bell please Council
Ambassador okay we have had two
nominations we'll go with the first one
uh which is uh councelor Vanessa Bell
um can we can we take can we take a vote
on that for those members excuse me
chairman yes counc Sid uh councelor Keys
is on PGA and overview and scrutiny and
that's not
permissible you help
Johson that's
right oh
dear sorry May
um internet just just fell out I've just
rejoined so I'm I'm at a bit of a loss
we we're at a bit of a conundrum in that
councelor Keys uh is on overview and
scrutiny and
pgna oh
okay um
well based on the the Constitution we we
can't do that as as per the the
discussion that's correct
earlier chairman can I propose someone
else as as a member yes I think you can
yes well I need a counselor that isn't
on um PGA or overview and scrutiny point
of order councelor leader uh can I just
ask um Mr Dodson if that is allowed
because I thought we just agreed all the
members of this of this uh
uh uh committee's chair previously on
agenda item 15 I believe and I think the
council did approve them all so now
we're asking to change them and I'd just
like clarification from uh Mr Dodson and
Mr quelch if that's allowed in our
constitution or whatever law it is thank
you chairman thank
you um Mr
CR
yeah no well obvious it's not that that
that that obviously can't happen if
councelor Keys is on both then the
Constitution it would be it would be
ultrav virus the Constitution so um um
councilor Bamford would need to would
have to rectify even though there's been
a resolution um we've now see that that
that that is against the Constitution so
councilor bampa would need to rectify
that um and and that would have to be
obviously agreed by Council that that
change can take place but as it stands
it has to be it's it's ultrav virus the
Constitution yeah okay yes council
banford do you have another name yes I
do chairman if I may if you'll permit me
to um propose Jane Fleming please
councelor
Fleming are you prepared to sit on that
uh committee Council
Fleming yes here I am thank
you right thank you we have to have a
vote chair though don't
we yes we'll need to have a a uh a
council vote uh to agree Council of
Fleming uh to go on to overview and
scrutiny um do we agree that by sorry
chairman just to just to interrupt we're
currently in a special meeting of O
scrutiny so we would need to journ that
meeting to go back into Council to
consider and then come back into o the
special opening scri committee okay I
haven't actually handed it over yet
because we haven't got a chairman the
point of order chairman that's the point
I was going to be raising actually um
it's agreed that the leader can nominate
uh sorry the councelor banford can
nominate as councilor sorry as Mr qu has
just said so why is the council vote
required I'm not quite clear
chairman where's that in the
Constitution
CH chairman it's it's simply because
although if I may chairman with your
permission um uh the 1989 act says that
Council Council has to nominate in
accordance with the group leaders wishes
or the group's wishes so you still need
a ratification of that technically okay
it is it is a ratification the council
can't really disagree with it
because ratification Mr quch thank you
thank you so are are members prepared to
ratify that bias sent yes
agreed thank you very much agreed agreed
agreed can we can we once again call for
those members when your name is called
can you switch on your video and your uh
mic please and then I will call for
nominations so Mr dogson could you just
call them again
please
okay we
have councelor
Bassinger councelor Beal councelor Bell
councelor Mae councelor Morris councelor
Bamford councelor Fleming councelor
moley councelor duick and councelor
Boyce thank you I will now call for
nominations for chairman for the
remainder of the municipal year to May
2021 yes please chair nominate councelor
Bamford councelor
bleming uh Mr chairman we had already
nominated Council Bell and that was I
just needed to I needed to have a a
second name from from that so we have
already got councelor Bell which has
been duly seconded so uh we can take a
vote on that from
from this uh
committee recorded vote
please I'll second
that Mr qu can you just help me uh is is
this am I going to call for this Vote or
is it going to be the members of the
committee well well well technically um
we're going to be technical here um
chairman uh the when that first proposal
was put forward I think the committee
wasn't properly constituted and it was
reconstituted yes so so you need to take
the proposal that was first of all
obviously a second proposal can be put
forward you can have more than one
nomination obviously but in terms if
you're going to vote um in the order of
voting then you need to take the first
nomination first for the reconstituted
committee okay for so these will these
will only be the members of the
committee who are voting so the
nomination was for
counselor counselor Bell as
chair can we have a rooll call of those
members on the committee please
Tara yes chairman I will do my
best so starting with councilor
Bamford and this is to vote for coun
banford as chairman is that right
chairman no well actually I think from
what Mr quch was saying um it wasn't
properly constituted so I guess we we
should have uh
councelor councelor banford uh is the is
the proposed one am I right yes I think
that is correct I think that's correct
that's the first one Council Bamford
right is has that been seconded I'll
second
chairman can I can I just ask please is
that really fair in the spirit of it
when we've allowed them to actually put
another name forward it wasn't our error
I don't miss I don't wish to be pedantic
but really I think in the spirit of
things the uh councelor Bamford surely
we could allow the first nomination
which was councelor Bell to be heard
first correct me if I'm wrong Simon Mr
quelch and and I I I take that if if I'm
wrong but I mean in the spirit of it
it's not very nice is it um I I'm afraid
um the spir unfortunately the spirit of
things you're asking my legal view the
legal view is the committee wasn't
properly constituted when that proposal
was put forward so technically the first
proposal put forward was that of
councilor Bamford that's the legal
position okay um I I don't adjudicate
chairman on on what's sporting or or or
what's in the spirit unfortunately I
understand I understand we we've got to
within the legal framework um Council
Thompson you got a point of
order no oh sorry chairman thank you for
coming to me but um I canceled it
because Mr F has cut with that thank you
right okay so the the nomination first
of all that this committee is voting on
uh is whether councelor Bamford uh is uh
the chair of this committee or not if
that fails I'll go to councilor Bell
so members of those so if you're ready
Tara we'll take that
vote Yes chairman so um if you could
indicate members for against or
abstaining please um starting with
councelor banford please or thank you
councelor Binger I'm sorry I'm slightly
confused who is this
for this is for councelor banford as
chairman against thank you um councelor
Brian bill
against you councel Bell against councel
Boyce
for Dick's not present councelor Fleming
four thank you councelor
Ma
against councelor
moley
for
Morris most definitely against
chairman I believe I've covered
everybody for that the result of that
vote is four four and five against and
no abstentions thank you okay that so
that has failed so then in that case uh
I will go with the second uh proposal
which is well as it wasn't properly
constituted I'll take that proposal
again um I propose that uh Vanessa
councelor Vanessa B
as um chairman thank you is that
seconded that's seconded thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh and we'll go with
the vote on that again this is for
councelor Bell to be chairman of
overview and scrutiny thank you Tara uh
thank you members um so if you could
just indicate for against abstain again
please councelor banford please against
thank you councelor
Bassinger thank you councelor Brian
B for you councelor Bell for thank you
councelor voice
against you Council
Fleming
[Music]
against cast
ma
four C
moley against thank you councelor
Morris wholeheartedly for chairman the
results of that is five for four against
and no extensions thank you thank you I
therefore declare that councelor Bell is
appointed as chairman of overview and
scrutiny and I will now hand over to her
as chairman of that committee to elect a
vice chairman thank you councilor Bell
thank you U Mr chairman thank you
members so um to open nominations for uh
the vice um Vice chair for the rest of
the municipal year and um from the chair
I would like to nominate councelor Brian
Beal thank
you and I'd like to second that Mr
chairman okay any any other nominations
I think councilor
Bell any other nominations um members
thank you Mr
chairman thank you
uh therefore I presume you're declaring
Council bill as Vice chairman um do we
need to go to the vote on that members
or to do that we can declare we can that
so and you're going to close the meeting
I think at 9:08 I will thank you Mr
chairman I will close the meeting at
9:08 thank you MERS very much indeed
okay we move now to the Joint standards
committee um if you could switch your
videos off please uh and Mr Dodson will
call out the names of uh the members for
joint standards thank
you thank you chairman we have councelor
Bassinger councelor ma councelor nun
councelor Sidle councelor Mrs Channer
councelor Mrs Fleming councelor Mrs
Thompson and councelor
Boyce
thank you very much I now call for
nominations of chairman for the joint
standards committee for the remainder of
the municipal year to May 2021 are there
any
nominations pleas Bassinger seconded
counselor
Channer sorry I I'm sorry I didn't hear
all of that um can I have any
nominations please I was first chairman
councilor Chana please I'd like to nomin
with a recorded vote right councelor
Channer by councelor
Thompson and I will second councelor
nuns chairman chairman can I can I just
ask yet again that people don't just
shout out councel Channer and elain
banford and myself at these pre meetings
were were very keen that members didn't
shout out and they were told to use the
chat bar chairman yes no nobody could
hear what what everybody was saying then
and the members of the public will be
thinking goodness
knows it is very difficult I would ask
yeah I I I feel for you chairman because
of course this did happen to me when I
was in the position of chairman both at
the meeting of the August the 6th and
other meetings in August and September
so I would say I do concur I recognize
the difficult position you might be in
but as I have suffered it myself as
chairman I think we have to recognize
that this may occur I do through the
chair um I do apolog oliz for calling
out um chairman um but it's the way that
I thought uh things were conducted it's
how it was when I started on the council
but I do apologize and I'm happy to use
the chat
function thank you for that Council
because I I thought I made it clear when
I was still in the chair about the
process but thank you for that it does
help councel herd I'm sure that thing
for me councel heard it is how we've
always it's the first time we've done
this virtually so um same
so I have I have two nominations one is
councelor
Chana uh and the other is councelor nun
who seconded councelor
Chana B coun
Ching thank you and who seconded
councelor none no chair it was it was me
oh sorry it was it was me um nominating
Council bass yes indeed
yeah
councel right okay that's fine okay I
will I'll take them in the order that
they came but I would ask for the next
one can we please have it on the chat uh
function so the proposal is uh that uh
for those those members uh to vote on uh
the chairman can I um so the first one
is for councelor CH have a
could we have a recorded vote Mr
chairman recorded vote is that
seconded uh yes chairman I did ask
actually but it probably got lost M yes
a recorded vote
then so this first vote will be uh for
councelor Chana to share joint
standards if fails we'll move to council
Bassinger thank you chairman members uh
if you could just indicate for against
or abstain please starting with
councelor
Bassinger
against councelor
Boyce
for councelor Mrs Channer
for councelor Mrs
Fleming four thank you councelor Ma
against you counselor
nun
against counselor Sidle
against
four chairman I think that's everyone
I'm just going to double check that I've
not missed
somebody so chairman I make that four in
favor and four
against very well uh in that case I will
use my casting vote
against so then I now call I now call
you don't have a you don't have a
casting vote um point of order of order
no I can't I can't have a point of order
because council is in adjourned so you
can't have a a a point of order no it
wasn't against you councelor Boyce it
was against what's happened no no no you
can't um you can't have a point of order
um I would have asked for a point of
order but as the council is adjourned
committe MERS there's no point but what
I what I wish to say is that um because
the council is adjourned and although Mr
uh councelor herd um is in the chair for
the nomination of chairman he does not
um have a cast in vote and the protocol
has always been to go back to council
now that may well be the same result but
that is what the procedure should be in
my view sorry
chairman chairman if I may say what
council voice says is absolutely correct
although you preside you have no casting
vote because you not a member of the
committee and it would have to go back
to council for the appointment of
chairman okay in that
case contion has to be maintained and I
agree with that chairman thank you
councel herd um for the uh obviously
you're a chairman that's um uh obviously
political thank
you not um um
I'm nearly trying to move the business
along right in that case we'll we'll go
back to council and then we'll take that
as a full Council decision is that
correct Mr quelch
yes yes be yes full Council have to then
appoint the chairman okay uh in that
case then uh we'll go with do I go with
the uh the first one again I think the
meeting has to be
adjourned yes CH chairman you have to go
back into as as councilor sches has just
said you have to now come out of the um
the meeting and go back into Council and
then you re you need proposals again
because it's a proposal from Council not
a proposal from JSC I understand I
understand okay um right so we'll go
back in into uh full Council again at
9:15 p.m. uh and we will be uh calling
for a vote for uh chairman on the joint
standards committee um is there a is
there are there any
nominations uh for chairman and I see
Council and none has a prop has a
nomination
um yes thank you chair so we're back in
full Council now then we are back in
full Council yes thank you very much so
in full Council I would like to nominate
councelor Bassinger as chair of joint
standards committee for the remainder of
the municipal year thank you and I will
second uh
councelor right so in uh in full Council
then we have councilor Bassinger who has
been nominated as chair seconded by
councelor Bell uh and we'll go to the
vote on that is that a recorded vote uh
can I raise a point of order yes
councelor skes I'm sorry I'm new to to
all this but I thought you had the the
meeting had to be adjourned first in the
that was existing before I mean been
adjourned we're back in full Council now
yeah I know but before we came back into
full Council it didn't it have to I'm I
just don't want to follow get tripped up
by some uh by a rule and I just want to
make sure that we're still okay to go
ahead if there wasn't an official
adjournment of the of the committee
being discussed yes there was we're back
in full Council now councelor banford
you've got a point of
order thank you chair I I just wanted to
bring up what councilor skines is very
ay put forward that you have to adjourn
the Mee meeting of joint standards and
then come into the main Council and then
the council is voting on The Proposal
that wasn't
agreed you know because it's equal votes
I don't I don't think I'm correct in I
don't think it's right that we're taking
another proposal because it hasn't you
know it's gone four four within a
committee so then it comes to the
council to agree or not to that not take
a new one am I right Mr Mr quch yeah
yeah who's that Mr quch
fluk enough sh I had a bit of a problem
with the um with the technology um uh
yeah you've got to the procedure is
you've got to
adjourn come out of joint standards into
for
Council counil then you need a proposal
from Full Council seconded and it's a
vote of full Council once CE that once
that um vote is taken and you have a
result then you can go back into JSC
with your chairman who will then deal
with the vice
chairman may I ask who adjourns that
meeting I have I have adjourned it and
we've now come back into full
Council that that's because chairman um
if I may say chairman you preside
according to the Constitution at the
annual meeting you preside over the
special meetings of each committee so
you can adjourn it as the person
presiding orbe you don't have a casting
vote you do
preside yes I understand that Council
Nan you have a
question um unless I'm mistaken uh chair
I think what council of Bamford was
suggesting is that that the the vote the
nomination in committee I.E um counselor
Chana is the one that has to be voted on
in for
Council is that right uh councel bford
and is that correct or not uh Mr quch
through the chair yeah through the chair
um I believe that is correct in
accordance with the Constitution but
obviously our monitoring officer
is um has got a different
opinion I I I was no no I was no I don't
have I was looking at some
constitutional issues I'm sorry I wasn't
playing full attention I was looking at
the Constitution while you said that I
could you just say chairman I understand
that councelor banford made a proposal
within for Council is that
correct no no no would no no uh through
you chairman just to clarify what I was
saying is what councelor nun confirmed
that um the standards committee had
taken a vote and it was Tha so when that
happens it then goes to council to
decide on that
proposal not a new one right okay is a
new proposal it is a new proposal
because it's Council now that are
dealing with
it so it needs to be a proposal from
someone in Council so I I nominate
councelor Chana no no no no through the
chair please I nominate councelor CH no
through the chair I had already
nominated coun passenger in full
Council and it had been seconded by
myself yes that is correct and that uh
that is where that is where we're going
to go so we're going to take the vote
for councelor Bassinger proposed by
councelor nun and seconded by councilor
ma if that fails I will go to the second
proposal M chairman so I this is voting
for counselor Bassinger as chairman of
joint standard committee yes and he
could indicate for against or abstain
please when I call your name councelor
banford please against thank you counc
Bassinger for thank you councel Miss
Bal
against whoever coughing against yeah
got that thank you Miss Bill councel
Brian
bille
councelor Brian
B councelor Bell yes sorry I'm back it's
moted uh for thank you councelor Bell
for thank you councelor
Boyce against you councel Mrs
CH councelor Mrs
Chana sorry uh can you not hear me no I
didn't hear you sorry sorry um just be
clear what are we voting for voting for
councelor Bassinger as chairman I said
against but something obviously wrong
with my mute because I'm showing my
mic's open and I'm saying it but you're
obviously not hearing it we can hear you
now though
so thank you and councelor
dorham councelor
dorham Edwards against Tara thank you
sorry C
counc Edward was for thank you coun
fling against thank you councelor fluka
against Miss burd thank you counc herd
for thank you councilor
H against thank you councelor
Hull
against for thank you councelor
Keys against thank you canc
lag sorry tar I couldn't find me crying
in kit so four please much councelor
Ma for thank you councelor
moley
against councelor
Morris most definitely po thank you very
much councelor none four thank you
councel
shessy four counc Sidle four Council
schemes four
Council
four
four counc Swain four thank you counc m
Thompson C thank you and Council Miss
White
okay results about chairman are 16 for
13 against and no extensions thank you
very much thank you in that case that is
car carried uh we'll now we'll now go
back into uh the special meeting uh so
I'll adjourn this council meeting we'll
go back into a special meeting uh of the
joint standards committee uh I declare
that councelor Mark Bassinger is
appointed as chairman and I will now
hand over to him uh for to call for
nominations for vice chairman Council of
Passenger thank you members thank you Mr
chairman um I now call for nominations
for the position of Vice chairman for
the rest of Municipal year for the JSC
committee nominations
please count on
somebody have we lost contact with
somebody Mr chairman um I would like to
nominate
um Elaine
banford thank you is that seconded
seconded councelor n are there any other
oh sorry councelor passenger so sorry
chairman we where are we I've lost yes
where are we we are Vice chairman of
voice jo
committee sorry we're in the joint
standards committee and you are being
proposed as Vice chair
I'm not on the joint standards on it
she's not on it not on standards
nominate J councelor Jane
Fleming seconded
councelor are you prepared to stand as
Vice chair sorry it's not my place up to
you councilor passenger sorry Mr
chairman are you prepared to stand um
councelor councelor Fleming I think
really that it should be councelor Chana
um because she was our nomination for
chair so would um members of the
committee consider councilor Chana are
you nominating A J yes I second that
nomination
good thank you members so the nomination
is is is councelor Chana um and I don't
think there's any other nominations on
uh councelor CH are you willing to
accept that
nomination um I am afraid I have to
decline well are there any other
nominations so the that only leaves I
nominate councelor Thompson I'll second
that if she wants it it oh no I'm afraid
I'm going to decline as
well so the the constitution of the of
the joint standards committee stipulates
that the chairman is from the from one
uh group and the deputy chairman is from
the second largest group so could Simon
CR please clarify this for
us um well that's right the the
Constitution says the terms of reference
I think it is say that
um chairman and vice chairman can't be
from the same political group I think
that's what it says so it could be
another political
group sorry
chair yes through you could I ask um
could we ask Mr quot I thought since
we're back to political balance then
that will have disappeared along with
this resetting council meeting yes here
here that's what my understanding
was
I that's that's what I'm not clear about
I I have to say I was very unclear about
that to be honest with you I was very
unclear about that resolution back in
June as to the disapplication of the
political balance Provisions yes they
only go from one from from one annual
meeting to another but um this
particular change um um I think was a
constitutional one um rather than just
the disapplication of the political
balance Provisions so I think that I'm
reading it unless members are telling me
otherwise that that decision was
actually to change the terms of
reference of the standards committee but
that's how I understand it and that is
actually how it is recorded in the
Constitution I was just looking at the
terms of reference and that is how it's
recorded then may I may I propose
councel Bo chairman may I come in then
no thank you that was my that was not my
understanding of what I've been told I
was told it was a reset and we would go
back to as things were at this meeting
which is not now being it seems to be
we're having a dichotomy now in what we
we can do part of it but not all of it
and that's not what I understood from
what I've been told previously right it
seem chairman if if I can can
help I think I think I think councilor
Sidle said it's got to be from the two
largest groups and he's right and that
part of the
Constitution uh was written into the
Constitution whereas the four and four
uh was only until the next statutory
annual so it should be somebody from
another group um but if you can't find
somebody from another group then you
don't have one chairman can I ask you a
question please sorry it's councilor
stamp yes
I don't remember the motion stipulating
that those words at all and I think this
is now being misconstrued about the
spirit of the joint standards committee
and as far as I'm concerned at the
moment chairman this is a backward step
we wanted to work we wanted to share
things and I think this is important
that a conservative member is the vice
chairman on this committee because that
is what this Council voted for I don't
if it was in May I can't I can't recall
chair
but I think we need to be very careful
here I presume we're being watched by
goodness knows how many people and I
think we're being semantic here uh thank
you chairman all right uh councelor
Fleming although uh you proposed
councelor Chana uh she has
declined uh so I think uh you were
proposed uh as Vice
chair coun
Fleming I thank you chair I feel that it
should be councelor chenna councelor
Channer doesn't want to do
it so the The Proposal is that I mean
we're trying to keep within the con I
know clearly what I was told about a
reset of the Committees and the motion
that was carried before and changed
things I was told now it was all reset
and went back to what it was and that is
what are my understanding was of
conversations I've had it's not
certainly not it's not my understanding
I'm afraid joint standards that when the
motion was went forward in the summer
The Joint standards committee terms of
reference was changed so that there
would never be a group that dominated
and that at that time it was four and
four if a political group had more than
three members then they would be
represented onto that and therefore
that's what we've got we've got four
conser four Independents three
conservatives and one Democratic
Alliance the the dep Deputy chairman uh
or vice chairman sorry has to come from
the conservative group that is what's in
the
Constitution right so uh the proposal
The Proposal is and I I see everybody's
trying to to speak but I want to try and
move this along so councelor Fleming you
have been um proposed as Vice
chair thank you chair I think councelor
banford wanted to say something actually
we're we we really are in a committee
meeting of Just The Joint standard
committee members so you really should
not be having I'm sorry L you should
have spoken um and we should not be
having interventions from uh the leader
of the conservatives either because this
is a meeting of the joint standards
committee is not a full council
meeting right so councilor Bassinger uh
you as chairman uh you have uh asked for
nominations
Council has has been uh
nominated um and that has been
seconded now I think in order that we
can move on uh I think perhaps we should
go with that because I'm trying to agree
with the
Constitution no point of order can be
raised if you are not a member of this
committee right so vote Mr chairman so I
need to know councilor Fleming what your
thoughts are um I think that councelor
may suggestion of a vote is is a good
idea um right yeah I personally feel
that councelor Chana should do it
Council CH doesn't want to do it so I'm
gonna go to the vote uh or or Council of
Bassinger you you'll go to the vote I
don't doubt well yes absolutely thank
you Mr chairman and as chairman of this
commit I would like to the vote and and
hopefully councelor Fleming you will
accept the position so should we should
we take the vote
please miss bird uh thank you chairman
um yes members so if you could just
indicate for against or obstain please
want to call your name starting with
councelor Bassinger please oh thank you
councelor
Boyce
obain
ch
abstain counselor Mrs
Fleming
abstain ke counselor ma uh four thank
you very much councelor none an
excellent Vice chair four absolutely
councelor Sidle four and councelor Mrs
Thompson
abstain chairman that
is four in favor nobody against and four
abstentions
thank you Miss bird well sorry very
bizarre
situation um then I declare Council
leming as Vice
chairman thank you no chairman sorry
sorry it was the voting was four four
four against oh yeah four abstentions
yes sorry just ignore me apologies
that's my mistake okay thank you very
much presum you're going to close the me
now thank you Mr yes I would like to
close the meeting of the joint standards
committee thank you okay closed at 9:36
so that is Council of Bassinger as chair
and councilor Fleming as Vice chair um
now I have to admit I've I've skipped
over licensing I will put that at the
end uh but the next one is the
investigation
and investigation and disciplinary
committee um could I
ask uh Mr Dodson to call out those
members of that committee
please thank you chairman yes we have
councelor
ma councelor Sidle councelor Bamford
councelor Mrs Channer councelor Helm and
councelor
Jarvis sorry sorry councelor
Jarvis isn't on that one it's the
disciplinary panel that on I apologize
for that
error so we got Council May Sid banford
Chen and
Har right okay thank you very much uh I
now call for nominations for chairman uh
of the investigation and disciplinary
committee uh for the remainder of the
municipal year to May
2021 uh Council S I propose my self I
would like to propose councelor Channer
and I will second councelor
sidel and I will second councelor
chair thank you very much uh the first
one that was uh proposed and seconded
was uh councilor Sidle uh which was
seconded by
councelor
maiz uh so could I have votes please in
favor of councelor Sidle as chairman
could we have uh the votes please
Tara uh yes chairman uh if you can just
give me one second I just get a she
upk
okay so uh this is for a
chairman starting with Council
sigle uh members again if if you could
just um indicate for or against or
abstaining when I call your name please
um and
first councelor Maz
please uh
four thank
you Council S
four thank you uh counselor
Bamford
against
thank you councelor Mrs
[Music]
CH you're
muted I had my my cop there's something
obviously wrong with my system at the
moment I said
against thank you very much and
councelor Helm
against so chairman the results of that
are three for and three against and no
abstentions
apologize I'm sorry chairman I've got
that wrong apologies no that's wrong
two4 and three against I think yes sorry
chairman I One recording incorrectly
apologies that's okay that's okay
there's been plenty of confusion tonight
don't don't worry about that okay so
that that is that is failed can I have
any other nomination oh I've got a
second nomination which is councelor
Chana which has been agreed by councelor
hell
so could we take a vote on that please
Tara yes of course chairman um so this
is for councel Chana as chairman um
didn't artical list which quite handy so
starting with councelor banford please
four thank you uh councelor Mrs
chna four did you hear that
sorry yes okay
thank councel helm
[Music]
thank
you um councilor ma
abstain and councelor Sidle
against results of that are three in
favor one against one exstension thank
you very much thank you very much uh so
uh I therefore declare uh that Council
Chana is chair of the investigation and
disciplinary committee and I hand over
to her as
chairman thank you very much Mr chairman
may I please call for nominations for
the vice chairman of the investigation
and disciplinary committee and from the
chair I would like to propose Elaine
banford and I ask for a recorded vote
chairman I'll second that chairman
councelor
Helm well that's to be that's to be
conducted within the committee
councilor CH you're the uh
chairman yes we got to do the
votes all those in
favor this has to be recorded I've asked
for recorded vote
chairman sorry that's my fault sorry um
just let me get sh and can I just
confirm councilor Helm with seconding
recorded vote as well that's correct
thank you councelor H um
sorry there me one minute sorry
chairman okay members so voting
for for vice chairman uh for Council
banford uh if you could just indicate
for against or abstaining please
starting with councilor banford four
thank you counselor Mrs Channer four
thank you councel Helm for thank you
councelor
Ma
against the
councel
against chairman that's three for and
two against thank you very
much in that case uh I declare that
councelor Bamford is the vice chairman
for the remainder of this Municipal year
until May 2021 and i' close this special
meeting of uh the investigation and
disciplinary at I think by my clock
chairman it's now
21:43 correct me if I'm wrong thank you
I'm I'm afraid to say it is councilor
Cher thank you well there you are you
can't trust these it equipments can you
there you go that's what I'm looking at
my laptop cheers okay thank you very
much uh so uh I um the next one on the
list is the district planning
committee um and I see that
councelor nun has requested to make a
nomination on this uh first of all can I
ask uh
Mr Dodson to call out the names of those
well in fact it's the whole council is
it not do you still have to call out the
names I'm happy not to okay so it will
be uh it will be uh everybody who is
included uh in that councilor none you
have a nomination well yes thank you
chair I mean it was always my
understanding that the chair of the
council was the chair of uh of planning
district planning but nevertheless if
we're going to do it this way I'd like
to nominate you as chair of District
planning thank
you thank you very much is that seconded
yes
second thank you very much uh I also
have another nomination from councelor B
F yes thank you chair I would like to
nominate Penny Channer councelor
Channer I'll second Mr chairman
I'll okay thank you any other
nominations right in that case uh we'll
have recorded vote please CH recorded
vote Yes we can is that seconded I'll
second that yeah thank you uh okay we'll
go with the
first nomination which was by uh
councelor nun uh which who who is
nominating myself uh could we have the
vote please miss
bird yes chairman of course uh so
members if you could just indicate for
against or abstaining please and this is
in relation to um councelor herd as
chairman um so starting with councelor
banford
please
against thank you councelor
Bassinger for thank you councelor
missv
against councelor Brian B for thank you
councelor Bell for thank you councelor
Boyce against thank you councelor Mrs CH
against thank you councelor Doren
against thank you councelor Edwards for
thank you councelor Mrs Fleming against
thank you uh councelor
[Music]
herd
Helm against Tara thank you councelor
Hull against Tara thank you councelor
Jarvis abstain thank you councelor
Keys again against thank you councelor
lagen for please tar thank you councelor
Ma four councelor
moley against coun
Morris
four four please Tara thank you
councelor
shy four thank you councelor Sidle four
thank you councelor sches fourk you
stamp four counc
stils
four Wayne four councelor Mrs Thompson
against ccor Miss White against thank
you thank you chairman the results of
that are 15 for 12 against and one
exstension thank
you thank you very much uh Miss bird and
uh thank you members and uh clearly I
have some work to do uh on my uh theme
of unity uh I'll be working hard on that
um before I go to the to the uh the
local uh planning ones I'm I'm going to
go back to
licensing to interrupt you and we need
to do Vice chairman for district
planning I'm sorry we need to appoint a
vice chairman for district planning
committee yes you're quite right quite
right
um sorry I've just lost my uh lost my
notes there
um so I now call for uh
nominations uh of uh Vice chairman of
the district planning uh committee and
from the chair I nominate councelor
Ma I second that chair
are there any other
nominations in the absence of any other
nominations uh I declare that councilor
ma is appointed as Vice chair of the
district planning
committee thank you for that um I'm now
going to move to uh move back to
licensing if that's all right um Miss
bird
yes chman that's fine with me yeah sorry
I I sorry I missed that one uh so um Mr
Dodson could we could we call out uh the
names please for those members on
licensing of course we have councelor
Bassinger councelor Beal councelor ma
councelor Sidle councelor
stils councelor Durham councelor Hull
councelor Mrs Thompson councelor
Helm and councelor
Boyce thank you very much uh I'm looking
at the chat and I see that councelor Ma
has asked uh to to
nominate uh yeah thank you Mr chairman I
would like to nominate councelor Richard
siddle as um uh uh chairman for this
Municipal
year are there any other
nominations could someone second me
please is that second
that than
you any other
nominations yes please I did put it in
the chat this time Council to nominate
councel Dar
please is that
seconded I'll second that Mr chairman
Council H thank
you
um okay uh well I think we'll uh we'll
go to the vote on that for those members
of the licensing committee um the the
first one was um councelor Sidle which
was duly seconded are you able to take
the vote please Tara does anybody want a
recorded vote on this yes please yes
please sorry I will second Council
Thompson thank you okay so uh this is
for councelor Sidle as chair of
Licensing okay members again the usual
for against obain please um starting
with councilor Bassinger
please for please
Tara Brian
bille Bri that's thank you
um councelor
Maz Pa thank you counc siddle for thank
you councelor
stils four thank you councelor
Durham against thank you councelor
Hall against har thank you councelor Mrs
Thompson sorry against sorry thank you
counselor
Boyce against thank you and councelor
Helm
against results of that are five for
five against and no
abstentions thank you
[Music]
chairman so uh it's it's another
tie so um I'll so we can either go back
to council or we go with the second um
proposal uh which which I'm in Mr quch I
presume you've gone now have
you I um I cancel my meeting chairman um
very kind of you um so we are drawn
there do I go to the you can go you can
yes you can because there was no
majority for the first you can go to the
second proposal um you can try that yes
okay I'll uh I'll try that uh and then
then we'll go back to uh we'll go back
to council uh depending upon the outcome
of there so uh it
is
uh the no nomination is for councelor
Durham seconded uh by um councelor Helm
so can we take a vote on that please uh
yes chairman of course um starting with
councelor passenger if you could
indicate before against or obain please
councel Passenger please against thank
you against thank you very much councel
Brian
bill against thank you councelor Boyce
for thank you councelor
Duram four thank you counselor Helm for
thank against oh
sorry four four councel h thank you very
much counc
M against thank you councelor
siddle
against councelor still
against Mrs
Thompson
sorry problem four four Council thank
you chairman the results of that are
five for five against and no abstentions
thank you very
much sorry could you just say that again
yes sorry chairman the results are five
for five against and no extensions five
for and five against okay so we'll take
uh we'll take this back to council
again and chairman can I speak can I
speak please yes Council Dar chairman
thank you very much um considering I'm
the only person on that committee that's
held a Justice's on license which I've
done since
1995 um it's a bit of a shame but I
don't wish to prolong this meeting any
longer um so I'm quite happy to stand
aside and let councelor Sidle take the
chair of this uh because in actual fact
the chair of these licensing meetings
are decided on uh at each licensing
hearing so the chair of this is actually
irrelevant thank you he's right he's
right well uh I'm I'm grateful for that
um in that case I declare uh councelor
Sidle to be chairman of Licensing and I
hand over the meeting to him okay thank
you chairman uh yes so I'd call this uh
licensing committee
and I call for nominations for vice
chairman of the committee for the
remainder of the municipal year to May
2021 do I have any
nominations do I have any
nominations we don't have
nominations so the Chairman's calling
for nominations for vice chairman of
Licensing
does anybody want to nominate
themselves Mr chairman as we as it was
pointed out by coun darham that when we
go into the actual licensing committees
we choose a chair and vice chair at that
time do we need to choose a vice chair
now
no I'll take advice from Mr quelch on
that
I you don't I don't believe you need to
choose a vice chair because if the
chairman is not available for a
licensing committee meeting we're not
talking about the licensing subcommittee
meeting but but a full licensing then if
the chairman is not there then members
can vote on who should chair for that
particular
occasion chairman in my experience on
the licensing committee that the actual
voted chairman has almost never chaired
the licensing hearings so it's it this
is this is pretty
irrelevant yeah correct right uh in that
case I'm happy to move on if you are
councel so yeah I I close the uh commit
licensing committee at 957 and hand back
to you chairman thank you very much
indeed uh the next one is the central
planning committee uh Mr Dodson could
you please read out the names of those
on that
committee yes we
have councelor Edwards councelor herd
councelor lagen councelor ma councelor
Morris councelor nun councelor shessy
councelor Mrs stilts councelor
Swain and councelor Miss
bill thank you uh I have uh one person
who wishes to nominate uh that is
Council and
nun yes thank you thank you very much
chair um so Central area planning I
would like to nominate councelor Michael
Edwards for
the
that that's that's been seconded thank
you did I see there's somebody else who
wanted to speak is there any other
nominations
no right
uh uh in that case um yeah chairman ah
um I'm I'm sorry to interrupt I did I
did go on chat um I realized I wasn't on
this committee this this these area
committees these area committees are
Ultra
vires if my vote
against um agenda item
15 uh and section 17 of the
1989 act are
compliant Tak ADV taking advice on that
councelor Boyce uh councelor ma you've
got a point of
order uh yes I was under the impression
that only members of this committee
could actually speak
all right yeah thank you very much um
counselor
nun well yes but I can't unhear uh
chairman what um Council Boyce has said
uh and my uh view on this is that we go
with the rules that we've been used to
and the rules that have always been
applied under previous
administrations and if uh councelor
Boyce's idea um is researched properly
by a legally trained person I.E uh Mr
quelch uh and if we do need to revisit
this then we revisit it later on but at
this stage we proceed as we are
agreed I agree agree on that um so in
the absence of any other
nominations uh I declare that the
chairman of the central area planning
committee is councelor Edwards and I now
hand over to him as chairman of that
committee uh thank you chairman and
members just one item of business I
therefore call for nominations for vice
chairman of the central area planning
committee and from the chair I nominate
counselor Janette
stiltz a second
please okay second
yeah are there any other
nominations
no okay thank you I therefore declare
counc stils as Vice chair of the central
area planning committee and as there is
no further business I'll close this
meeting at 10:00 2200 hours thank you
thank you very much
um uh we now move to Northwest
planning uh Mr Dodson could you could
you call the names for the members of of
that committee
please yes of course we have councelor
siddle councelor Bamford councelor
Durham councelor Mrs Fleming councelor
Keys councelor moley councelor Mrs
Thompson councelor Miss White and
councelor
Jarvis right thank you very much uh now
I have had notification on the chat uh
that councelor banford wishes to make a
nomination so I call for nominations for
chairman of that committee councelor
banford yes I put it in the chat
chairman I want to nominate Maddie
Thompson please councel Thompson
Thompson
seconded yeah seconded are there any
other
nominations in that case I declare
councelor Thompson as chairman of
Northwest
planning committee and I hand over to
her uh for the remainder of this
meeting um thank you chairman thank you
members um uh I call as chair as new
chairman for Northwest planning I call
for nominations to the vice chair and
from the chair I nominate councelor John
Keys could I have that second
second thank you second are there any
other
nominations
thank you that being so I declare
Council John Keys as Vice chairman of
Northwest planning for the remainder of
the new Municipal year and I close the
meeting at
2203 thank you
chair thank you very much uh councelor
Thompson uh finally Southeast planning
uh Mr Dodson could you call out the
names uh for nominations
please Council coun Bassinger councelor
Beal councelor Bell councelor schemes
councelor stamp councelor Mrs Channer
councelor Hull councelor Boyce councelor
duick and councelor
Helm thank you very much I'm looking at
the chat I see that councelor Bell
wishes to make a
nomination uh yes please Mr chairman I
would like to nominate councelor skes as
chair please I would like to second that
please
chairman thank you are there any other
nominations yes please
chairman councelor Cher I'd like to
nominate Richard duick
please is that
seconded I'll second
[Laughter]
that okay I'll go with the I'll go with
the first one uh that's councelor Bell
is nominating councelor schemes um could
we have a vote on that
please thank you chairman um members if
you could just indicate when I call your
name if you're for against or abstaining
please and this is for Council schemes
as chairman of Southeast era planning
committee um so starting with uh
councilor Bassinger
please four thank you Council Brian
Bill thank you Council Bell
for left meeting counc M CH
against thank you
counselor councelor
H
against sorry
chairman councelor schemes for thank you
councelor stamp for
sorry T oh sorry I've missed your
apologies councelor hel sorry against
thank
you uh and councelor Miss
White she's not on there
on sorry sorry
members it's councelor Boyce unless I
missed him but he's left the meeting
sorry tar I was trying to help sorry no
no that's really helpful is real thank
you uh so chairman and I think I've
covered everybody hopefully the results
of that was 54 and three against and no
extensions okay in that case in that
case I declare councelor Nick skem as
chairman of uh Southeast planning and I
hand over to him uh to uh call for a
vice chair uh thank you chairman I now
call for nominations to the vice chair
for this committee and from the chair I
nominate councelor Vanessa Bell I'd like
to second that please
chairman thank you thank you have a
nomination from councelor chna uh I
nominate please councelor Michael
Helm thank you very
much um so I will uh I'm sorry I didn't
I didn't see who was first on that
whether it
was councelor Bell or councelor coun
bell councelor bell it came from the
chair thank you very much off from the
chair
yes
um well it's up to you then up to you
then chairman uh to take the vote on
that yes uh please Tara could you call
the uh members and let's have a vote Yes
of course chairman uh so as before
members for against to obain if that's
okay um starting with councelor
Bassinger please can we just be sure who
we're voting for um
Tara yes of course this is for um Vice
chairman for councelor Bell thank
you four thank you was four thank you
very much councelor Bill Brian Bill four
thank you councelor Bell for thank you
coun building counc Mrs Cher against
thank you thank you very much councelor
Helm against thank you councelor Hull
against thank you councelor schemes for
thank you councelor st four chman the
result of that is five four three
against and no extensions thank you very
much well thank you I now declare
councelor Vanessa Bell as the vice chair
of this committee I now close the
meeting at
2208 and hand back to you The Marvelous
new chair of molden District
Council thank you very much um thank you
Council schemes right um we now move on
to the resumption of uh business and so
we will resume the business of the
annual council meeting uh at um
10:09 uh we move to agenda item 18 which
is the appointment of Representative
to local government and outside bodies
this was sorry could I just interrupt we
chairman we just need to go back and do
appointments board because we didn't
appoint that because we didn't know who
the chairman and vice chairman of the um
two committees were going to
be quite right quite right um okay uh Mr
Dodson could we call out the names of
those members of the appointments board
please
yes we have
um councelor
stamp councelor
Bamford sorry chairman of strategy and
resources um Sidle councel Sidle
councelor Sidle thank you chairman of
performance governance and audit
committee councelor still
and councelor
Helm and there are two other members
that need to be appointed by Council
um both so those so those members are
appointed to it uh and we need two more
is that
correct that's correct yes okay uh
looking at the chat I have councelor ma
who wishes to
nominate
councilor ma yeah so sorry Mr chairman
uh yeah I would like to nominate um
councelor
Jarvis I'll second that so sorry if I
could just come back on that that
chairman we have there should be six on
this committee um three from the
Independent group so we have three I
think with the um the appointments of
the the chair and vice chair um there's
um we just need the conservative I
think I think we need to appoint two
don't
we I was under the impression we needed
to appoint two Mr
chairman it says six on the six yeah
burners comeb back is
two okay so chairman just to clarify
we've currently got the leader of the
council the leader of the opposition the
chairman of strategy and resources the
chairman of performance governance and
audit which is four so if if it's six in
total we'd need two
more yeah what about the nomination from
the Democratic Alliance on the on my
order
paper yeah I I have that and councelor
SS if as May answer
say well I think we need to I think we
need to we I think we've already got the
number of correct number of Independents
am I right Mr doson that's correct right
so we need to have a conservative and a
uh D is that correct there is one it's
on the order paper I've got councelor
Helm that's myorder
shows we only need one from the
conservatives if I'm reading this right
I'm sorry to interrupt chairman but I'm
sorry my order paper seems to be saying
different things to what people are
saying and I'm a little bit concerned I
agree the order this is the order paper
I've received tonight agreed agreed mine
is person yeah correct may may I come in
um
chairman yes I have had meetings with
Cheryl Hughes with Wendy as leader and
um we were told that there would be
another conservative Place depending on
it if you had Independence in the other
positions which you have now officially
so I would like to nominate councelor
Chana which I did try to do this morning
when we had an agenda meeting but they
told me I would have to do it in
Council um once we knew who the chairs
were of the relevant committees so I've
now done that second I'll second thank
you thank you councilor
stamp
so uh sorry have we got one one or two
because I'm getting I'm getting mixed
messages
here I understood chairman there was one
conservative yeah yeah she's right she's
right that's what my order paper shows
me chairman sorry to interrupt but my
order paper is making it clear there's
one other conservative to be appointed
the rest are already now determined
following the elections of the chairman
of SNR and PGA we know who the leader
opposition leader is
so hel is there for the DCA or sorry the
da and therefore it's just one other
conservative right underneath it does
say plus two others political balance
does needs to apply so it says that
underneath um point of order chairman um
Wendy um sorry councelor stamp and
myself have just agreed what was
discussed
with um the officers and it's just one
conservative that's what we've both
agreed just now that that
was can I come in sorry sorry Mr Dodson
I'm so sorry Mr dson I I was just going
to confirm what council of Bamford said
it is one conservative that needs to be
added it should be six on the committee
the the two may be misleading where it
says two but it should be one person and
then based on the political balance it's
one conservative can I come in there I
think that was maybe because we didn't
have at the time or previously the
Democratic Alliance Group and I think
that's where the confusion may have come
but council banford is absolutely spot
on CH okay can we can we agree that by
Ascent councelor chenana on the
appointments agreed agreed agreed agreed
right thank you very much that is agreed
uh so we're okay now to move on to
agenda item
[Music]
18 right appointment of Representatives
to local government and outside bodies
um so before I call on the leader to
introduce this item please note that
under recommendation two representatives
of the following outside bodies have yet
to be agreed Bradwell local community
liaison
council local area highways panel molden
and District youth strategy group and
the stone Mar's Aerodrome consultative
committee uh if you wish to speak on
this item please make this known by
using the chat function within the
meeting I will then come in and uh or
come to you in turn Following the Leader
of the council's
presentation please keep your points
clear and concise bearing in mind
time of the night uh leader please
introduce the report uh thank you uh
chair um it's quite self-explanatory
anyway this um agenda item um councelor
uh Bamford and I both need to be
applauded we have worked very hard to
try and come to some agreement but as
you can see chairman and members there
are a couple of um committees or no a
couple of working groups where we
couldn't really agree so it has to come
to count
so without further Ado while they me
rambling on I think we just need to take
it through you Mr chair in the order
that it is it's quite
self-explanatory uh Council banford and
I have highlighted where we've got too
many on there and I do regret we
couldn't come to a an agreement so it's
down to full Council to agree thank you
chair okay thank you very much councelor
banford you wish to
speak
thank you chair it is rather late so
it's finding um the place of all these
but if I can firstly deal with the
problem with the Bradwell local
community liaison Council I think that
was the one where
um we had hoped to have um the same
number of members each so there would be
an equal number of Independence and an
equal number of conservatives and I
think we couldn't come to an agreement
there for some reason um obviously we're
we're trying to go forward in the vein
of cooperation and liaison as you quite
rightly pointed out in your Chairman's
um note and um I just don't understand
why
um the independent um leader at the time
wouldn't agree to us having an equal
number on
there that was the first one um the
local highways panel because again I
know planning isn't political but we do
have um quite a number of conservatives
on Northwest area committee and I wanted
to have one of our members on the
highways panel I propos Jane Fleming
who's from the Northwest area planning
to be on there um but that wasn't agreed
the other one is the um Stow Mar's
Aerodrome where we would think it
sensible to have a w member on there um
and as it was argued many times before
that Ward members should be on the areas
where the locations are in their area
and and this is actually um in the ward
of conservative members we wanted to
have a conservative appointment on that
on that body um the other one is the
youth strategy and again we have an
holler who has been um on there for some
time and has done a lot of good work and
I think she does have an appointment to
a certain time and that's why we wanted
to keep her on so that that's the four
issues of dispute here um and we just
can't come to an agreement over it but
that's my reasoning why I wanted um what
I've asked for on those committees but
we did come to agreement on most of the
others so you know I think we've done as
Wendy has said councelor stamp has said
um we did well to get to this
point okay leita do you want to come
back on that I do but I'm not going to
prolong the conversation I said said
from my uh delivery we couldn't come to
agreement there's no point in me trying
to justify anything I really do feel it
needs to go to the council uh for the
the votes on them chair and you've got
them councelor uh Bamford has explained
them quite eloquently We can't agree
them so we're going to have to take them
one by one and I do apologize to the
late hour but but um we are not going to
compromise so is going to have to go to
full Council thank you chair here here
sh
well sorry chairman to be a party pooper
here but I want to speak if I may on the
main embodiment of the report and ni 3
in particular which is placing
responsibilities on members on these
outside
bodies regarding the minutes uh in the
report chairman there's various bodies
highlighted and in
3.3.1 it mentions stonar is and the
molden you uh molden District youth
strategy group local areas panel and
Bradwell local community Ling Council
with all du respect chairman the M
District youth strategy group is not a
body that MN District Council has any
control over it is an essics County
Council body that has been set up with
the um intentions of the cabinate member
and the head of Youth Services what that
b what the M youth strategy group is
about it's linked to the youth Str uh
Youth Services which is a a a remit of
essics County Council a molden district
councelor May sit on that but that's in
the remit and of course they're
appointed and normally for a year
because uh we've just appointed the
chairman of that molden new strategy
group it's me again so I I I am aware
what I'm talking about because I'm an
Ethics County council member hence of my
declarations earlier and I'm very
concerned that it's saying that members
of Moren District Council regarding the
minutes of that body it is for them to
have the responsibility to share with
everyone many of those minutes are
private and confidential which I know is
Carri carried by the 3 .4 but I'm sorry
chairman I don't think there's been any
discussion with essics County Council
here equally I'm concerned and councelor
Durham may have a view here on the local
area highways panel again that is a
committee under the purview of Essex
County Council and it is chaired by an
ess6 County councelor and I'm very
concerned that molden District Council
is choosing to appoint what it feels it
should appoint without any sanctioning
from the embodiment of Essex County
Council without any agreement of the
chairman of the committee of mod and
District youth strategy or indeed how
the youth strategy groups are rung and I
have to say it's nothing personal but
I'm very concerned that this report says
that and then the responsible member
would be one who can share the minutes
when a member is pointed in an outside
body it is quite clear the code of
conduct you follow and the terms of
reference you follow and everything else
is the body you're appointed to not that
of molden District Council and I will be
be having to take this back to Essex
County Council because it does concern
me um and I'm sorry chairman if I sound
a party pooper but I think we need to be
very clear of this and there are certain
things about the lhp that was agreed and
not agreed councelor Durham might be
here and he might be able to say but I'm
concerned about little three and the way
uh those bodies which Essex County
Council established commit uh committees
they could say we don't want a m
District counselor if they chose to but
we're saying now we want two and I'm not
going to argue neily with that I there
might be ways that can be achieved but I
think it is very very serious to start
then implying in three that that molden
District Council appointed to an out an
Essex County Council body with its remit
and its responsibilities can share those
minutes in the way that MN District
Council suggests it should sorry
chairman all right thank you for that um
councilor Bell you've asked to
speak yes pleas
yes please Mr chairman um in relation to
the youth strategy because as everyone's
aware this is a position that I'm very
interested in um as councelor Channer is
also
aware I am very well qu I'm not one to
blow my own trumpet normally but I
actually believe Essex County Council
would want the best qualified person in
this role and with all due spect due
respect to counselor Hall I'm a
qualified teacher and social worker I
have been working with young people at
the sharp end and in more strategic
positions for over 25 years I don't
think you'll find best qualified person
to fill this role than me thank you here
here here here thank you coun come
back yes briefly on that Council CH yes
I've said nothing against Council Abel I
understand what she said however I may I
think with all due respect she may not
realize the experience that councelor
Anne Hull has and I can tell you has
been invaluable to the molden youth
strategy group I don't wish to break
confidentialities because a lot of those
meetings we have confidential
information what I will tell you is
councelor an Hull and her experience and
what she deals with and what she has
done and what she stands for and I'm not
I'm not going to break confidentialities
and her experience of certain areas with
young people and children is it been
invaluable to that
group thank you councelor
darham yeah thank thank you chairman uh
I think gosh um anyway yes let's the
local highways panel yeah as councelor
Channer said the local highways panel is
not a molden district council committee
uh it's an Essex County Council body the
membership of which consists of the
three divisional Members Plus one member
uh from each of the area planning
committees um and the chair of the local
highways panel is a County council
member so this is a uh so when we come
to fill it uh there has to be one
nomination from each of the area
planning
committees okay thank you very much
councelor
Fleming thank you chairman I just wanted
to speak about the sto mari's uh
consultative committee um I see that uh
councelor Stamper nominated uh to
Independence I just wanted to explain to
members what what that actually is it's
a consultative committee with the
neighbors so you have to have the ward
member on there you have to have a ward
member because they consult with the
neighbors so to not have a ward member
on would be frankly
ridiculous um so I don't want to sit on
it uh so that must be councelor white
I've argued in the past um
that items that are specific to a local
area the ward members should be onor so
that's my opinion thank you thank you
councilor
SW yes thank you I have to say I gree in
time with councilor Fleming um and that
um if she is not if she has disqualified
herself then I entirely agree that
councelor white should have the um place
on it um not me thank you councelor SW
thank you councelor
none thank you thank you chair two
points really uh first a simple question
how were people put forward for the lhp
and Youth strategy committees in the
first place that's the first question uh
how were they put forward and the second
question is uh and I'm sorry if I'm
breaking this idea of unity chair but
isn't it amazing how suddenly Ward
members need to be involved with their
Wards when for for months and months
that certainly has not been the
case okay so we have uh we have a
question question there uh councelor
Durham you might be able to answer this
as as chair of the uh highways panel how
were they chairman it's very it's it's
very simple Council appoints one member
from uh each of the planning
committees that that's so you Council
needs to nominate and select one member
from the central area planning committee
uh one member from uh Southeast and one
from one from Northwest okay chairman I
mean well as as as you councelor
councelor heard you know you you
obviously represented the central area
for some time yes and then latly
counselor Harker so it's it's very
straightforward
sir okay thank you very much um
councelor councelor lean you've been
very
patient thank you chair it's just a
comment really um I'm very much enjoying
the debate but after councilor Flemin um
has mentioned that it's absolutely
critical that W members should be on
working groups etc etc and it's
outstanding that that should be the case
now that's been brought up after in
previous Council meetings uh and I
remember a resolution being put for by
councelor Swain was unanimously um voted
down by all other conservative members
so um I'm very pleased that that Council
Fleming has has had a change of heart
and and decided that the things that we
should do are the right things to do so
it's a comment and a statement
not a question chair thank you okay that
comment is
noted councelor B you have spoken once
on this but I'll I'll hear you
again sorry chairman but I just wanted
to emphasize to everyone that this is
going forward this is the council going
forward and we can't be looking back to
what we did before you know I I've
always said I'd cooperate and liais with
you and as leader of the opposition now
I would do that but you know if you're
not going to do that then fine but this
is what I wanted to do going forward and
that's why I wanted to have an agreement
on having Ward members on particular
working groups and outside bodies and
also having a split on um working
parties so we have the same number of
Independents and the same number of
conservatives and now the new party as
well so we all work together so you know
it's not what happened in the past we're
going forward now in a positive and
proactive way I sincerely hope so
chairman okay thank you I will come to
councelor Thompson but I'll just let
leer come back on that point um yes uh
uh councelor banford and I did discuss
this earlier at a meeting and yes I'm
totally uh in agreement in going forward
uh but I H I did explain to her you
can't sweep everything under the carpet
when it suits you uh and um I think the
the points are being very well made
tonight and I think we're just
prolonging this debate it's not going to
we I thank councelor Fleming for what
she said and councelor Swain so we I'm
quite happy to concede on that one so we
can take that one off the list of voting
chairman if it speeds it up uh but
Council Langer made a fantastic point
you can't just sweep things under the
carpet um we are trying to go forward
but please don't expect every everything
think overnight uh and I I actually want
to propose that we go through the
outstanding groups that we haven't
agreed with uh as per the list thank you
chair thank you finally go I'll go to
councelor
Thompson thank you chairman um one is
something of a
comment things like star is aad drone
which situated in a Ward and affect only
that Ward are very different from for
inance car parking um which is situated
in one particular W but actually affects
the whole
District um the other comment I was
going to make so you know if we're going
to go refur backwards and the lead new
leader has done so if we were doing it
all wrong for 18 months um I have to ask
the question why are you going to do it
all wrong for 18 months why don't you do
what you said we should be doing um in
the first first place this snacks of
Revenge frankly thank you chairman oh oh
chairman I don't accept that that is
absolutely a ridiculous thing to say and
I will not lower myself to be able to
respond to that thank you okay we'll
we'll move over that councelor Fleming a
last point from you because I know
you've asked the question before thank
you councelor her I was just responding
to councelor lag earlier um I've just
for the record I've always argued that
that Ward members should be on Ward
issues in fact if we all rewind back to
Market Hill that was the uh vote that I
abstained on that caused the fera and I
abstained on the principle that um
councilors nun and may should should be
on that working group um so just to for
the record I have always been a champion
of Ward members particularly where it's
very Ward specific
being being on there because the point
is is
that we're elected and we represent not
just the people that voted for us that
we represent everyone people that didn't
vote for us that that's the principle
here which is why really with the
Bradwell be there should be more
representation from
conservatives thank
you right I I want to uh I want to move
this along really
um I'll just take a couple of more a
couple of more speakers it's going to be
councelor Durham and then councelor
Channer and then I want to move to the
vote because I think we've had this long
enough yeah sorry chairman we're all
getting very tired and and uh I I I
haven't got the papers in front of me I
haven't got the list in front of me
because my iPad's run out of juice for
some peculiar reason I wonder why um I I
and it's somebody has put a note that
there have been four nominations for the
local highways p panel put forward and I
just say that that is contrary to the
terms of reference of the highways panel
it is three Molton District members one
from each planning committee area thank
you right that seems straightforward to
me um councelor Cher the last word well
just to make the point I hear what
councelor Fleming said um I represent on
S6 the division of mm with Market Hill
and it's not just about the world
members with all due respect to councel
n and councelor Ma it involves all uh M
than W members
and in fact it involves all wider people
because hence the reason why as agreed
by the air quality management area
action plan ess6 County Council have
agreed to do a transport strategy not
just to look at Market Hill but to look
at much wider areas in fact everything
that comes into molden to look at how
the transport is managed it's a
recognition it's a districtwide matter
because what you do with Market Hill is
going to have an effect on not just
molden it's going to have an effect on
wider areas haybridge and Beyond staris
is very clearly specific it's in the
Parish of staris it's the residents of
staris who have views on that they will
obviously go to the where Ward
Representatives direct about staris it's
not worried so much about the wider area
it's those residents and I think there's
a succinct difference between Market
Hill comparisons council with all due
respect to council n and councelor Ma
and other Ward members of mold
because other it affect councelor darham
in h oh sorry sorry councelor Morris in
haybridge and other people whereas Stone
Maris is quite specific and I'm very
aware of the matters because I was on
there as a m District Council
representative and they had me on there
because of my Jewel hats and I'm sure
there's a way that I may get on there
again but I'm not I'm not going to
prejudge that but I know what star is
would want okay thank you I'm I I feel I
feel so inclined to speak with councelor
Ma and councelor none actually as
they've been mentioned on the air
quality councelor
ma uh yeah no Mr chairman I wasn't um
going to say anything on this I'm sorry
I saw you that's okay thank you Mr
chairman you cancel none yes I mean I
can't leave that chairman you know I've
heard this argument before that market
Hill affects the complete District but
Brad will only affects the parish uh and
it's quite frankly it's nonsense and in
fact I I was the person who chaed the
last Market Hill meeting ironically
enough because very few members attended
so um you know let's not mix those up
and as far as staris is concerned it's
of national if not World importance and
therefore it has an economic impact on
the district not just the parish thank
you very much thank you I I will hear
from Mr I can't raise my hand I'm on my
phone um but I wonder if you'd indulge
me to allow me to speak uh yes I will I
I know that councelor Hull has had her
hand up for some time although I can't
see her on my screen so I go to councel
Hull and then I'll come to you councelor
why thank
you councelor holds hand hand is down
now so councelor
white uh thank you Mr chairman um I
think it might be helpful to give a
little bit of background on the sto
mari's if I might because the only
reason it came about was because the
residents were irate and the Airfield
was equally iate and they were they had
a standoff and the only way that we
could get any dialogue going was to
organize um the working group to try and
bring the two groups together and
actually it's worked really well we
don't get involved with the operational
side of the Airfield we don't have
anything to do with the Airfield at all
other than than trying to solve the
issues between the residents and the
Airfield that all the working group does
it doesn't do anything else at all
because that's not our remit the running
of the Airfield is down for charity H
and I have to say we've done a good job
because it all seems to be relatively
peaceful at the moment but that is the
only reason it was set
up all right thank you I'm going to go
back now to the leader uh to move the
recommendations as set out in the report
thank you
ler um chairman yeah I'm sorry I'm just
same as everybody else getting a little
bit wary um we have agreed um to um the
hang on bear with me to the
staris uh councelor nun and councelor
white because councelor Swain um very
kindly um withdrew so we can cross that
off so we've agreed with that is that
agreed uh chairman and members can we
agree that by asent agreed agreed agreed
thank you me thank you members I
appreciate that now the the next two are
going to be the sticking points members
and and you may want a recorded vote
chairman it's down to you the Bradwell
local community liaison Council we uh at
Council bamford's been put forward Lagan
Ma skines and Council of white now
there's only four members and cser
banford and I did try agree on this and
we couldn't so I think it's going to
have to go uh to a vote chairman all
right we'll take these one at a time
then uh so first of all the bradville
local community leaz on Council who are
you proposing for that I'm proposing
counselors um lagen ma skin and
Bamford and I will second
that right and would like a recorded
vote please
it's local
representation okay so can we take a
recorded vote for uh the Bradwell local
community liais on Council councilor
lagin Ma skes and
banford Mr chairman could I ask a
question please yes councilor bill go
ahead thank you what about the word
local in this uh committee set that
we're talking about um it seems that
there's a lot of people have only just
heard about Bradwell and I do believe
there should be someone from the denji
hund on that
committee council skes is the
representative for for out
here that's my proposal chairman and
that's what I would like to be put
forward thank seconded that with AOS
seconded so can we take that to the vote
please un unless unless Council want to
agree by
Ascent no all right okay a recorded vote
then we don't no okay uh could we have a
recorded vote please Tara I'm sorry
about this welome chairman um members um
if you can just indicate for against or
abstaining so this is the Bradwell um
lclc um and it's councel lagen Council
ma councelor schemes Council banford so
starting with councelor b
please I'm against because I wanted
another
conservative to be equal with the
independence okay can I just ask because
of the time could we just say for or
against please I appreciate that that
you would like to add yours but I'm
trying to move this along for or against
thank you thank you I'm against because
it's not thank you thank you very thank
you Passenger please oh councelor Miss B
against thank you very much councel
Brian
B four thank you coun
Bell thank you councelor Boyce he's left
does council Mrs
CH against and I will say this chairman
because coun I just want to know against
I'm sorry councelor chel I want for or
against councel white knows what the DJI
people are thinking for or against thank
you councilor Doren please against thank
you councelor Edwards for thank you
councelor Fleming against you councelor
Fluker councelor
fluka councelor herd for thank you
councelor
Helm against thank you councelor
Hull
against Jarvis
for councelor
Keys
against counc
Nan four please Tara thank you councelor
Maz uh four thank you councel
moley
against
Morris for thank you councelor
nun thank you councelor shessy four you
councelor Sidle
four counselor skes
four stamp four thank you Council STS
[Music]
four councelor
Swain abstain thank you councelor Mrs
Thompson
against okay
thank you chairman the results of that
is 15 for 11 against and one exstension
thank you very much thank you so
councelor lag and May sches and Bamford
are on the Bradwell local community yis
on
Council um leader uh local area highways
panel yes please I'd like to uh propose
that councelor Michael Edwards councel
Richard Sidle and councelor Wendy
Stamper on the local highways panel
thank you Chair seconded by Richard Sid
thank you any other
nominations we agree that by asent
chairman no chairman brother nomination
we have a recorded
vote you're sorry you're all talking to
me at once I've had a request for a
recorded vote uh and that's what I'm
going to do um so miss bird if you could
take the recorded vote this is for
councelor Edwards Sidle and stamp to go
on the highways panel
yes chairman of course um can I just
confirm that recorded vote was seconded
please second B thank you very much okay
members so this is for the local
highways panel um if you could indicate
for against or abstain please starting
with councelor banford against thank you
councelor
Bassinger coun Miss B
against councel Brian Bal for coun bell
for counc Mrs Chen
against
for Fleming
her coun helm
against
hold against councel
[Music]
Jarvis
four oh councelor
Keys
against
lag for please Tara thank you counc Ma
[Music]
forley
against Morris
four four please
Tara
four for
T stamp four ke councelor STS four coun
Swain
oh Mrs
Thompson against
Miss
White against you chairman the results
of that are 16 for 11 against and no
extensions thank you okay that is pass
councelor Edward Sidle and stamp are on
the highways panel um leader mden and
District youth strategy group yes please
thank you chair I would like to nominate
counselor uh Vanessa Bell um because I
don't think we've begin we've been given
the information if there is a time um
limit on this I did ask the officers uh
which councel Bamford will hopefully
agree with me on WE Tred to assertain
the information and I think um Council
banford was going to ask uh councelor
Hull if the officers didn't know but on
the basis that I have got no further
information I would like to propose
councelor Bell that is the
representative for the molden and
District youth strategy group thank you
chair and I will second that Mr chairman
thank you we have a propos proposal
which was duly seconded uh is that
agreed by
Ascent no chairman no V Mr chairman
we'll go to we'll go to a recorded vote
uh councel chair you to
speak sorry you wish to speak councelor
CH well I'm sorry U councelor stamp the
leader with all du respect as John said
our officer should know I thought I'd
explain this as an Essex County Council
body it's not for our officers to
determine what the appointment basis is
as I've said I'm the chairman of that
body and it is not therefore for M
District Council officers to say what
the appointment time
isect this is disrespectful to a body
that has been a remit set up by the
cabinet member and the head of youth
services at is sorry councilor stamp I
saw you put your head back in
disagreement with me I'm sorry I think I
do deserve a bit of more listening to
when I'm associated with ethics County
CC that committee I'm very sorry but I
feel quite strongly in my earlier
meeting and I'm just trying to protect
Essex County Council on this because it
is their body it's under their terms of
reference set up by the cabinet member
or the funding comes from essic County
Council and they determine about length
of time of people on it and who and
essentially the Partnerships they want
to work with they commission Services
it's not M than District Council
chairman I'd like to come back yeah I'm
not taking anything personally it is on
here to be voted on and agreed if I am
breaching any Constitution or any rules
then perhaps uh Mr Dodson and Mr quelch
will tell me I'm only acting on the
papers that I've been given and duly
elected as the leader to represent
members that are going to serve on these
committies so if councelor Channer feels
that I've overstepped the Mark I do uh
apologize to her but I'm only doing what
has been instructed on the papers thank
you chair all right councelor banford
you wish to speak yes sorry chairman but
I think
counselor uh stamp is not actually quite
right because the papers that we
received from the officers actually
indicated that this was a um an
appointment that wasn't needed because
it was running still now we haven't been
able to establish that but if the
officers information was that they must
have got it from somewhere well ects
again chairman this conversation has
gone off outside this I'm sorry chairman
but I won't be talked over I did have I
I
speak it's not fair that I should be
spoken over no I'd like to hear what
you've got to say councelor bford I'll
come to cancel St well I I'm I'm just
advising you that we had a paper from
the offices that actually said that we
didn't need to appoint anyone in this
position because they consider Ed the
appointment was still
running and therefore we haven't been
able to establish that Penny seems to
think P possibly it does run um for a
certain term under the County Council so
I I I think it should remain as it
is Chairman if I may speak can I can I
speak back we need to ask the officers I
was just about to say Mr Dodson can you
help
sorry I don't have that up my fingertips
I'll um I'll have to check unless unless
councelor CH as the the chairman of that
group can advise us on the the term I
certainly can I can tell you what I'll
be doing chairman I will be raising this
matter within the cabinet member I will
be going to the cabinet member forth
with and the head of Youth Services and
saying that MN District Council um has
two appointments and and and issues like
that we ask for an outside body and in
fact fact I think MN District Council
have turned into something it was
councelor Sue White initially councelor
Sue White has been coming to some
meetings although councelor an Hull is
the appointed member and I've made that
quite clear to the m new strategy group
we ask other members to come in that are
useful and there's a whole you know
remit of other organizations we do have
officers of molden District Council we
want to but it's Essex County Council
who stes the membership of this
committee not molden District Council
all right can I ask a member we want a
member
chairman yes Mr quch to to avoid um to
avoid a decision made by Council which
could run contrary to the to a possible
appointment yeah it seems sensible I I
just wonder chairman whether this should
be deferred yeah and conversation held
by officers with ess6 County Council
about it yes do we agree that by Ascent
agreed AG chairman agreed chairman
chairman may I may I add something I'm
speak councelor Durham hang on a sec
councelor chair councelor darham you're
next chairman yes I you know I I'm sure
I can help you uh um councelor Channer
is quite correct this is one of those
appointments that is a timed appointment
you may recall yourself chairman that
there are certain outside bodies that
are uh appointed for a set time and
we've even had the case where members
who are no longer members of M District
Council actually have to serve out their
time afterwards now this is one of those
appointments in in in my belief so um It
Whatever the appointment time was that
has to expire before a new appointment
is made but I'm sure the decision uh to
defer is quite correct and this can be
checked in due
course
before on
coun what I would say is being chairman
of that committee on tics County Council
perhaps I could have a word and see if
there could be any objection to two
members coming on but it would have been
rather nice to perhaps had that
conversation before this occurred I may
be able to with the cabinet member and
the head of Youth Services and the
molden youth strategy group see if
there' be any objection to two members
of molden District Council coming on I'm
just I think I think I appreciate that
gesture councelor Chan are you happy
with that councelor stamp now we've
deferred it I'm totally happy but I also
don't want to take the blame of
something when I've been asking the
relevant questions and not being given
the answers thank you chairman I think
no blame no blame has been Le I think
that's I think that's why uh that's why
these particular uh items haven't been
able to meet on an agreement but I think
we've agreed a way forward that we can
defer that one and I'm going to move on
to star's Aerodrome consultative
committee
leader chairman I thought we' agreed
with that one have we not agreed is is
councelor white um sitting on that one
now councelor Sway With do we do we
agree that by Ascent agreed
AG
agre okay so so we'll move to the uh
move to the recommendations leader
[Music]
chairman sorry U yes I propose the
recommendations as is with the
Amendments that we've already just made
chair yeah is that agreed by
asent
AG
chairman sorry that no is that no
councilor bford yes the the third part
of this which P counselor Chana argued
about I don't agree I with councelor
Chana we can't expect members to um be
responsible for putting minutes of
outside body
um outside bodies onto our um sites we
can't do that I thought there was an
amendment to this chairman can I come in
and help maybe help can I ask Mr Dodson
to speak because this was AED earlier
and I think what coun Mr Dodson actually
turned around and said because there was
some concerns about private and
confidentials and I think coun Mr Dodson
explained it quite clearly and I don't
know if he's willing to explain to
council which may assist members before
they agree or disagree with list three
thank you
chair thank you Mr
Dodson yes thank you um yes we we
amended the
um3 under um 3.4 of the report yes
updated yeah um and and it was
highlighted that we propose that members
have the visibility where papers are not
private and confidential and subject to
the agreement by the relevant body that
the appointed representative then um
uses the fresh service link to to for
those to go on so it's only with the
agreement of any group that is being sat
on and it's where wherever they're
confidential or private then they
wouldn't be required in any case so I
don't think we would be um overstepping
the the terms of reference of any group
because it clearly says in the report
now that the that group can refuse and
and to put those minutes for us to put
those minutes on if it's not appropriate
okay are you satisfied with that
councilor
banford um I'm not because the
recommendation doesn't say that it says
the recommendation says that members
appointed as representatives to local
government and outside bodies are
responsible for sharing minutes of
meetings attended to the
stored uh centrally on the molden gov
Library d d da so you know no I think
that's the recommendation what what um
Mr Dodson has very kindly pointed out is
what is in the report but it's not
actually in the recommendation and so
I'm not happy to agree the
recommendation as it stands I think it
does say it does say Council now exiting
that it in three that it is as per the
details in section three 3.4 below if
you go to page 18
3.4 uh it says we propose uh that
members have visib ability where papers
are not private and confidential and
subject to agreement by the relevant
body so I think it is saying
that I still think that we shouldn't
make members responsible for
that why should they be chairman I think
I put a recommendation forward can we
take it to the vote please unless
councelor banford and councelor Channer
with well within their rights would like
to make an amendment to any of
those clear in 3.4 counc CH with all due
respect chairman they're my minutes I
sit down with a with a commissioner from
Essex Youth Services we have the meeting
we we have a business person from Essex
helping and we determine the minutes
they're actually my minutes and I have a
real problem chairman I'm
sorry all right well in that case we'll
have to take it to the vote then in that
case um so
uh carara could we take a vote on that
please on uh number number three I
think are we are we happy to agree uh
one and two by
asent agreed yes yes agre you so it's
number number three then which does say
subject uh subject to
3.4 uh and it says where they're not
private and
confidential so Tara could we take
a vote on that please of
course so members voting on
recommendation three um if you could
just indicate for against to obain
please starting with Council banford
thank against thank you councel
Bassinger for thank you councelor Miss
B against you councelor Brian B for
councelor bell for thank you Mrs CH
absolutely against because of uh what
the just for against please I need I'm
very conscious of the time just like it
minuted thank you sorry I heard someone
say thing in the background would they
like to repeat
it just for or sorry chairman someone
said something in the background can I
have it repeated
please I didn't hear it it was it was
blood count otherwise yeah I would repat
you said what they said come forward and
repeat it please didn't hear
it I would like it repeated
chairman what did you hear councelor
chenna I heard someone say something I
want it
repeated did you hear counselor Channer
councelor Morris I don't have to be
answerable to you and you are asking a
question of us now I'm not sure
ioun moris councel Morris I will go by
the
recording
do that councelor CH I will go by the
recording councelor Morris it's not your
right not your right to coun will you
please stop
engag chairman would you please ask
councelor Morris to stop asking me
questions what I heard I don't not
answer them to I want to I want to move
on please right can we continue with the
vote thank you chairman councilor Durham
against
Edwards for
counc against thank you Council herd
for councel Hall
against
Jarvis councel thank you very much
councelor
Keys
against councelor lagen four please Tara
thank you councelor Ma
for you counc
moley
against four thank
you four please Tara thank you Council
shaes four counc Sid four Council SCH
four thank you counc four thank you
councel STS
obain
against sorry was that me to a bit
Thompson it's against thank you thank
you and I believe Council Miss White has
left yes so chairman the results of that
are 14 for 10 against and one abstention
thank you very much that is carried
please and and please can I remind
members please keep uh their thoughts to
themselves uh and make sure that your
microphone is muted uh I really want to
finish uh this meeting uh uh as soon as
we can now I'm very conscious of the
time I'm moving on to agenda item
19 oh first of all I think we yeah we've
done all that right okay gender item 19
appointment of members to serve on
working
groups um before I call on the leader to
introduce this item please not that
under recommendation two the nominations
for the Brad willbe Power Station
working group are yet to be agreed and
there is also one vacancy on the Leisure
contract task and finished working group
and the corporate governance working
group which is to be appointed by the
council uh members a reminder if you
wish to speak on this item please make
this known by using the chat function I
will then come to you in turn Following
the Leader of the council's
presentation and I'm asking you please
keep your points clear and succinct and
can we have although it's getting late
uh can we still have politeness and
civility to each other please uh leader
thank you uh thank you chair um I think
you've said everything uh I'm not going
to prolong it it's quite
self-explanatory uh Council banford and
I did try our best yet again the there
are a couple of queries on here which is
what you've nomin which which is what
you've said which is the corporate
governance working group uh and uh
Bradwell uh and I don't know how you
want me to proceed chairman do want you
would you like me to make uh nominations
from um the leader's chair or would you
like okay okays for Brad will be Power
Station working group okay well Brad
will be Power Station working group um
we couldn't agree on the uh the N the
numbers and I would like to nominate for
that group uh which is seven because
obviously the grade items are the the
statutory ones so we've got councelor
Bamford councelor Bassinger uh Chana
Fleming Hull langum Mae and shessy hang
on one two three four five so I would
like to nominate
Bassinger um Hull langum Mae and
shaes does that make sense one two three
four five I've got there uh Chan and
banford to all of them
and I will second
that okay so you did mention Council of
Fleming but that would make eight oh
sorry I do apologize it is getting very
very late um so we will um I will not
nominate U councelor Fleming okay so
it's councilor Bamford Bassinger Chana
Hull uh Council Lang Lagan sorry
councelor Ma and and councelor shaes
yeah thank you for your assistance there
I'm I'm actually getting very tired
councelor banford you wanted to
speak yes please chair because I think
um members should know why we couldn't
agree on this one because if you look at
the um the makeup of this working group
um it is the leader and Deputy leader of
the council the chairman and vice
chairman of strategy and resources which
are now all independent members and
seven members of the council
and I put
forward um three members did I no four
members I put four members forward
because I had an inclination that
perhaps the other people would all be
Independence so the again in the
interests of cooperation and liaising
together um I thought it was fair that
we had um a bit of an equal number of
people on here um because
obviously The Independents think that
they want to domineer this um this
particular working group which was
really not what we had hoped would be
the way forward um so I am disappointed
very
disappointed I understand that I knowe
that there are that it's four
Independents and three three
conservatives that's your proposal CH
that's the proposal of the leader so
that means you've got the majority of
Independence on this particular working
group which you know goes against what
your intentions as chairman um you know
it's not equal chairman can I come back
because it it maybe goes against your
intentions but it was the leader who
proposed this uh and I I feel that's a
little bit unfair that Council banford
have said that to you um but I've made
my proposal I've had a seconder um and
I'd like to to suggest we move um um to
the proposal for a vote and a recorded
vote please chair okay thank you very
much sorry sorry the chat that I wanted
to speak um CH I wanted to go on this uh
working group
because members perhaps are not aware
that the pinch point in terms of traffic
during the construction phase is
actually through my ward so I would
argue that I do need to be on the
working group
um it's the Ring Road around South
Woodham and the roads coming off are
going to be a big issue so I feel that I
really should be on this working
group thank
you okay thank you very much uh well
we'll all have the opportunity to uh to
vote now I presume nobody wants to agree
this by
Ascent noly not we'll go we'll go to uh
the vote then please
Tara thank you chairman so members this
is for Brad will be and it's council's
banford Binger Chana Hall Lagan Ma and
sha so you indicate for against to
obstain please coun banford against
thank you
Binger you coun
miss against thank you councel Brian
bille for thank you Bell for thank you
councelor Mrs Channer
against thank you councelor
darham against thank you councelor
Edwards
for councelor Mrs Fleming against thank
you councelor
fluka councelor
Helm Al left counselor heard for than
you
against
Jarvis
keys councelor
keys councel
Lagan four please Sarah thank you
councelor
Ma for C
moley against thank you C
Morris four thank you councelor none
four four you C Sid four C sches four CC
stamp
fours
SW
yeah councelor Mrs Thompson against
thank you and councelor Miss White
believe she's left chairman um the
results of that are 16 for eight against
and no abstentions thank you very much
chairman thank you in that case uh that
is carried uh I now move to the Leisure
contract task and finish working group
could I have nominations please leader
um chairman are we are we not doing
corporate governance working group first
chair I'm just going by the list next
one all right that's fine okay um the
Leisure contract task and finished
working group um the proposals are we
need eight members we've
got you've took me out of order now one
two three four five six seven uh one
vacancy for a council appointment and I
would like to nominate councelor Carl
Jarvis for that please
chair okay could I have the other
names sorry councelor dur dur Durham
Fleming Hull nun stamp stilts and
white I got most of
those um so I've got councelor Jarvis
Durham Fleming Hull
stilts Nan and white was it yeah it's on
the order paper chair all it is it says
at the bottom add add one vacancy for
the council appointment which is what I
would like to to nominate and propose KL
Jarvis okay thank you any other
nominations can I have a second it
please I'll second that
second okay uh do we will we agree that
or should we take it to the
vote chairman I would like to speak
please on this okay you haven't
indicated again something that we
couldn't agree um we had eight members
and it we had agreed most others half
and half four members Independents four
members
conservative and um I'm quite surprised
actually that an independent seat is
being offered to a non-aligned
conservative so I would like to ask
councelor Jarvis if he would if he wants
to take this position and if he um
agrees then um if you're going to take
the vote I would like it recorded
thank
you okay it looks to me as though there
are it is four and four you've got
councelor white councel Hull councilor
Fleming councelor
darham
chairman yes that's correct that's
correct chair what I'm saying is that
you we agreed to have four each so four
Independence for
conservatives but you're actually
offering your independent seat to to a
non-aligned conservative member which is
quite unusual so I would like to ask
councelor Jarvis if he wants to accept
that nomination from the
independence and if he does so and you
go to the vote I'd like it recorded
please okay councelor Jarvis are you
prepared are you prepared to sit on this
on this working group well chairman um I
am prepared to sit on that working group
I think it should be noted for the
I currently chair that working group
exact I've currently been I've currently
been involved with drawing up the
agendas being involved with steering us
through where we've got to and we're
currently sort of halfway through a very
difficult period with the sort of coid
issue and obviously um prospects of
further lockdown measures so as I've
been in touch very much with Steve
Butcher and the whole team there of
officers I would have thought it was in
the council's interest um for me to
continue um steering that group so
certainly I like to be on it um um and
and and in those
circumstances um I would have thought
the conservatives might might have liked
to have put me forward um in the
interest of the council as a member on
that group but if if they're not going
to put me forward I'm happy to put
myself forward um but it seems I've got
to rely on the independence and I thank
them for that thank you chair okay thank
you very much I've got two more speakers
C it's can canceran Bal which what item
are we on now because I'm starting to
lose it this is member training plan was
next no this is agenda item
19 okay thank you okay councilor none um
yes just briefly chair I wanted to say
that councelor Jarvis has chaired as a
member of this working group uh I can
say in my experience councelor Jarvis
has been an excellent chairman and in
the in the in the flavor of of
continuity and Ma matching what you want
uh chairman
collaboration I I think it would be an
excellent
choice thank you very much councelor
chenana I think uh I think your question
has been answered councelor bford
councelor
chenna I don't think I um oh did I I
must have sorry um B said it perhaps I
was going to ask um Council Jaris said
he's relying on the independence um he
seems to think then um who put him on
before I'm not quite clear so it must
have been the conservatives I
guess all right well chair chairman was
that relevant no it's not it's not
relevant and I'm going to move to the
vote thank you sorry I think it is
relevant thank you councilor
stamp right uh can we move to the vote
please uh Miss bird uh yes chairman
thank you and members this is for the
Leisure contract task and finished
working group and the members proposed
are Council Durham Fleming Jarvis Hull
nun stamp stils and white I think I call
that right um starting with Council
banford if you could indicate for
against for abstain please thank you
against councilor
Bassinger
for
mville against counc
branville four counc bell four counc Mrs
chna
thank you councelor Goram again you
councelor Edwards
four Mrs Fleming against thank you
councelor
herd councelor
Hull against councelor
Jarvis for thank you councelor Keys
against thank you councelor
lag for please Tara thank you councelor
Maz councelor Maz four thank you
councelor moley against thank you
councelor
Morris for thank you councelor nun four
thank you councelor shessy four thank
you councelor Sidle four thank you
councilor schemes I think I've just been
deafened by councelor Morris but
thank you councelor stamp four please
Tara thank you councelor stils four
Council
[Music]
swainson
against chairman and that is 16 for nine
against and no
extensions okay that's passed thank you
and finally I move on to the Leisure
contract task and finish working group
we' just done that one done that sorry
uh I'm one line up so I'm on the third
line now the corporate governance
working group uh which is to be
appointed by the council yeah has
anybody asked to speak on this yes
please yes I do councelor banord yes
thank you chair well I'm a bit confused
about this because when I'm looking at
what I've got here um it doesn't say
anything about an
appointment um it says that it does have
six members and there are six members so
I don't they are to be appointed yeah no
no no no you're saying there's another
one to be appointed well I can't see
that's the
case it says the corporate governance
working group to be appointed by the
council yeah with chairman can I help it
it's because we have to appoint this
because there is going to be a query
I've spoken to the offices on this uh
and I was advised that I could put um I
want to make an amendment to what is
proposed uh for the representatives on
this group and it states quite clearly
it's councelors Chana Durham nun Sidle
stilts and Thompson yes and as the
leader I would like to propose that
councelor nun comes out of that uh
corporate governance working group as an
amendment and um councelor Jarvis is is
put in his place and i' like to second
that counselor
sidol happy to give way chair thank
you and councelor Jarvis are you happy
to serve on that
group chairman yes I'm on that group I'm
happy to continue serving on it again i'
love the conservatives to perhaps put me
forward to serve on it but they haven't
done I do hold professional childood
qualification ations in governance as I
have stated before and I feel I can
serve the council well on that group
thank
you thank you very much um I so are we
are we happy to do that by Ascent no C
chairman no okay we'll take it to have a
recorded vote Mr chairman recorded vote
is that seconded yes councel B yes
okay okay Tara if you could take the
vote again please sorry chairman can I
just ask something was was councelor
Jarvis already on the corporate
governance working group yes he
was yes he was on there he was he was
taken off and now he's been put on
again so can we go to the vote please
Tara uh yes chairman members of voting
for corporate government's working group
proposed membership is councilors Chana
Daren Jarvis nun Sidle stils and
Thompson starting with councelor banford
please against thank you councel
Bassinger for thank you counc MF sorry
chair point of
order yes
C error sorry I've been taken off of
this in favor of councelor Jarvis yeah
apologies chairman i' I've added councel
Jarvis and forgot to take councelor on
of my list so
the membership is CH dham Jarvis sidles
stils and Thompson okay thank you very
much thanks for that councel that's okay
it is getting late Tara I understand
that well done councelor Miss Beal
please against thank you councelor Brian
B for thank you councelor Bell for you
CC Mrs
chel can you hear me yes I can hear you
against thank you very much councelor
Durham against thank you councelor
Edwards for thank you councelor Mrs
Fleming against thank you
councel left councelor herd or thank you
counselor
Helm is also left councelor
Hall against thank you councelor Jarvis
for councelor
Keys
against councelor lagen four please Tara
thank you counc
Ma councelor Ma oh sorry for thank you
councelor moley against thank you
councelor
Morris
none thank you councelor
shessy four you councelor Sidle four
thank you councilor sches four thank you
councelor stamp four you councel stils
four councelor
Swain Mrs Thompson against thank you and
coun Miss White has left so chairman the
results of that are 16 for nine against
and no extensions thank you very much
thank you that has uh that has passed
now uh so the
recommendations uh leader that the group
approved those
nominations and they've been appointed
to those groups yes can we do that by a
sent chair or do we have to do a
recorded vote on what we've just
recorded oh I think we've recorded it
all our members happy to well not happy
will they agree to do that by Ascent
agreed Mr chairman I've been asking a
question I want ask a clarification on
one of those groups yes councilor STS
yeah is the coid 19 reset and Recovery
members working group I believe when it
was set up that one of the counselors
that was on it was the leader um which
was councelor fluka when it was set up
he was then replaced by councel banford
but I don't see the leader on
there is does the leader have to be on
that
group
sorry CH can I come back on
that reset and Recovery I think
councelor fluka was on the that working
group but uh he didn't ever chair
it from
memory sorry chairman if I can can come
in there I believe that it was six
members of council and the councelor
fluka when he was on it was one of those
members not as leader of the council but
as one of those six members was my
understanding okay so canair thank you
so we've agreed that by Ascent I
believe agreeded agreed agreed thank you
I think I think we're almost there
members uh agenda item 20 which is a
member training plan uh and we move to
this uh which is found on pages 37 to
40 uh in a moment I will call call on
the leader to introduce this item uh if
you wish to speak on this item please
use the chat function I will then come
to you in turn uh following the leader's
presentation leader please could you
introduce the report uh chairman uh yes
I'd like to uh propose the report uh
about councelor training which is
composed by uh cherl Hughes uh to the
council I do think there are some uh
debates to be had here though chairman
so I I'm not going to uh propose the
recommendation if that's okay I'd like
for it to be debated first thank you
chair okay well I'll move the
recommendations in order that they can
be debated will anybody second
that yes I'll second it next thank you
I'll now invite members to make any
comments on the report Tara can you
advise me anyone who's asked to speak
please oh yes chairman I've got Council
about
councelor Sid and councelor Durham has
requested to speak thank you chairman
thank
you thank you um Mr chairman yes whilst
I um heartily approve of a members
training program and I think to be
honest it's uh well
overdue um I have to I have to say that
with all due respect to offices I
believe that we need certainly in some
areas to to have outside expertise for
this training um particularly members in
terms of overview and scrutiny and again
no disrespect meant whatsoever to the
officers but I I think we need to look
externally for some of this training and
I'm I'm not really happy that it's uh
all officer Le members I'm
sorry councelor
Sidle yeah thank you chairman uh I agree
with uh councilor Bell on this at the
moment we yeah I'm really pleased that
we're getting a trailing plan for po
members however at the moment it is a
it's a list of vague titles and what we
really need for us to approve as a
recommendation is a detailed training
plan and that planing training plan
should have defined modules and for each
module there should be clear training
objectives and training outcomes for
members this should be presented to to
come back to strategy resources or to
for Council for recommendation um if we
are on the radar which it specifies in
the report by the ministry of housing
again this is quite vague and if this is
the case why hasn't it been reported to
the district planning committee
previously um and if this is the case
then I think it's really important that
we are provided with external training
especially with regard to planning uh
this should also be applied as councilor
Bell said to overviewing scrutiny if
this committee is going to be a friendly
critic of the council the training
should be provided by external
Consultants independent from the offices
thank you chairman here here here here
thank you very much did I uh see
councelor daram wanted to speak on
this yes chairman he had indicated and
also Council banford has yes I've got
that thank you chairman I chair chairman
I I apologize I I actually I wanted to
POS uh a hypothetical question to a
director just before this item started
um I'm happy to to withhold that or with
your Indulgence just ask a a question of
uh Mr
Dobson yes go ahead um Mr dson on on the
basis that a lot of the the toing and
throwing we've witnessed tonight this
very long night has been due to the um
the political balance and the various
changes that have come about uh I I
would just like to know if there are if
there are changes between now and May in
the political groupings for example if
any of the members of the new alliance
return to the conservative group or a
non-aligned member is forced to join the
independence for whatever reason how the
whether whether uh this would be
Revisited at that time or whether we
wait until the next annual meeting just
a question of clarification chairman I
thank you for your Indulgence than very
please chair point of order please yes
point of order Council
Morris I'm sorry but did I just hear
councelor darham say forced to join the
independence well I think he for forced
is too strong a word I I accept your
criticism councelor Morris um is is uh
uh oblig
you thank you very much councelor darham
I'll let you off considering you are
wearing a stunny dick out chairman I'd
like to raise a point of order what has
that got to do with the agenda
item chairman I did say I wanted to
indic I I indicated before that agenda
item started it was just a a delay I'm
happy to take that question if it can be
answered briefly Mr
Dodson uh thank you chairman yes uh
without reference to the the
Constitution
and bearing in mind I'm getting very
tired but but my my understanding is
that we wouldn't revisit the the
political balance until the next
statutory meeting of council um at which
point it would reflect um what that
is that's my understanding as well okay
thank you very much
um uh
leader you chair
um well I'm actually in members hands to
be honest with you um I think we've
heard I think we've heard some excellent
suggestions um I think councelor Sidle
would like to make a proposal or an
amendment to a recommendation uh
councelor Sidle uh yes so um I would
like to put forward an alternative
recommendation um that the immediate
training is provided for chairman and
vice chairman to enable the new
Municipal year to commence that before
the training commences training
objectives will be specified to the
attendees item two for all other modules
a detailed training plan is presented to
strategy resources for each module a
course description is provided to
members with training on objectives and
outcomes clearly specified that planning
training and overview and scrutiny where
appropriate external providers are
sought to provide independent expertise
now I can copy those to uh Miss bird she
wants to I was just very worried about
Miss bird trying to write down at that
speed I will I will copy into a chat if
you if you could do that meanwhile I
have got two other speakers councelor
banford and then councelor
Thompson thank you
chairman um don't fall off your seats
anyone but I'm going to actually
agree that we do need to look at
external um training I did ring bring
this up myself um and we have got a
training budget in this
Council and we could use that um I'm not
quite sure that we need it in such
detail that councelor Sidle has proposed
and I think he mentioned Municipal year
well we we are in a municipal year and
um it goes to May next year
so I'm not sure his wording is actually
right that he's proposed um the next
Municipal period that's what I mean okay
and I'm not sure that any of this should
go to strategy and resources because
this is about training for the whole
Council so it should come back to the
council not to straty
resources okay thank you happy for that
okay thank you councelor Thompson
next thank you chairman
um yes I agree with the outside with
some outside training not least because
our offices what with coid and
everything else are under an enormous
amount have enormous workload and we
have had items we've had it mind you
we've had outside training on planning
in the past and yet you know we do still
have some very very strange decisions
coming up against all the evidence
provided in the
reports um I would also like to see
training on standards there because we
again have had some very inconsistent
decisions and we have had
um we've had results that go totally
against the evidence in one case um
members were roundly criticized for
voting against the evidence um and in a
later meeting
different members did exactly the same
thing and seem to think that was fine
okay so this is getting General support
thank you Council counselor CH if you
could be succinct
please not you particularly but any
other speakers now councelor CH well
thank you chairman because I appreciate
we're all getting late and um past my
bedtime I'll turn into Cinderella
shortly um yeah I agree with that
actually councelor Thompson has actually
said some of the things I was going to
say regarding standards so I think the
code of conduct chairman estic County
Council I hate to say that word is very
very sharp on uh training for members on
Code of Conduct between not only members
and officers but member to member and I
do think that is required in this
Authority chairman and I think tonight
to a degree is an example of that and
previous meetings of this Council
certainly ones I've chaired and I do
think that's required and I do agree
with external people regarding the LGA
looking at us um I'm aware I don't
actually sit EX offici on any of the
Committees but I'm aware that in recent
meetings of various committees not
Southeast I hastened to add there's been
some things where quite frankly the
local plan which is actually the
Secretary of State's local plan it's
ours now we adopted it U it appears
policy went out the window and I'm glad
it's not Southeast that is responsible
for that so I find that quite concerning
when we took such a long time a period
of over 10 years um to see some uh
planning applications um being throwing
out our our agreement the local plan and
especially the Secretary of State's
involvement with it it does concern me
highly I acknowledge there's areas of
gray erors in policy but I think that's
why we're under the microscope regarding
planning these things do get back um
applicants take it back residents take
it back other members take it back and
they do watch and glad it's not
Southeast but it is another committee
chairman thank you very much councelor
daram I I'll allow you to come back
briefly because you have spoken I I no I
do I I I I do support this um uh because
our our training actually our training
when I was first elected was very
formally you will recall say yourself um
chairman because we joined at the same
time um and it has deteriorated quite
severely uh the new members uh voted in
uh May of last year have not had the
luxury of many many of the courses that
we had um and I think it's extremely
important the only thing I would say um
and we've had this debate in relation to
planning training sometimes external
Prov training providers can be extremely
expensive now there are certain areas
where that is Justified but certainly in
the past we've actually utilized
officers uh and even members from other
authorities to provide training where
they have that particular expertise uh
or indeed even our uh training by our
own officers in some circumstances is
perfectly acceptable uh I we just don't
have the money to go Bringing In
external Trainers for absolutely
everything although I totally
acknowledge uh that there are some areas
where this is important as I said H and
Essex County Council have a very very uh
stringent uh training regime for new
members and member development that
carried out all through the year we
don't have any of that and as councelor
Chana has said things like the code of
conduct we actually have fairly regular
briefings on and I would I understand I
understand what you're saying you
support this councilor Darren but I do
want to move on thank you very much
councilor Fleming
finally thank you
chair I uh just picking up from um what
councelor Darren was saying about the
cost of external training um I'm not in
favor of going to outside bodies at this
point in time I think we've spent enough
on ourselves I think we need to actually
save the money and spend it on our
residence that's my view
anyway okay
um canel counselor Bell I really will
finish with you and then I'm going to
take this to the vote thank you very
briefly and very controversially and I'm
sorry um chair but we seem to have money
to spend on Consultants when we need to
so I think we have money to spend on uh
equipping our members with the expertise
that they need to do the carry their RS
appropriately thank you I do I do know
that I do know that there is money in
the budget so I'm going to go back now
uh leader you have
um you've had the benefit of councelor
siddle's uh uh motion as well um and I
think Tara you should have
that I take it we're going to go to the
vote for that yeah with the amendment
chair with the amendment could we see
that could we see the amendment please
Tara I don't has has councilor Sidle
sent it because it's was quite a long
Amendment no I have sent
Itor are you able to separate that
out have you had time to weave your
magic on that Tara with me a
second just get it onto a paper that I
can share
okay obviously chair it's got to be
within the budget yeah yes yeah okay it
does specify that when it's needed not
not that it's obliged to that's the if
appropriate is the
wording I think it should be for
everybody yes please I mean I mean in
terms of the external money
okay chairman that's the proposal that
councelor Sid
made okay so that has to be amended to
be presented to full Council instead of
strategies and resources
yeah okay okay um I think there was uh
General agreement on that uh not sure
about councilor Fleming but uh did you
want to take a vote on that councilor
Fleming um thank you chair my um issue
with this is that I feel that we have
spent enough on ourselves over various
issues and I just feel that spending
money on external trainers it is not the
time to be doing that is my view so yeah
it only says we appropriate it doesn't
say that we will so I'll be happy if if
it's you know in the next Municipal year
just not at the moment when our
residents are actually struggling our
business are on their knes I just don't
really feel it's appropriate for us I
think the money is is already allocated
uh for training actually well I'd be
happy to take that budget and spend it
on the residents and the businesses you
know there are businesses on the High
Street we don't have the money to um you
know spend on a marketing campaign to
support them yet we're quite happy to
blow money on training ourselves I just
really disagree with that all right
thank you very much coun Thompson I know
you've been very
patient oh thank you chairman um yeah
I'm afraid I can't quite agree with
councelor Fleming um I don't think we're
spending this money on our entertainment
if we were taking ourselves out to a
socially distanced dinner I would be
absolutely in agreement but we're not
doing this for fun we're trying to do
this in order to do a proper job and
having seen particularly some of the
planning decisions and arguments I've
seen um I really think we need to get
this right
thank you but I'm absolutely councelor s
you know external wear appropriate
because planning training in particular
has got to be mold and Centric and under
line with our local development plan and
our area our area committee system thank
you chairman thank you last word
councelor
Morris no okay right in that case I'll
go back to uh the to the leader uh then
and we uh you're happy to present it yes
I'd like to propose uh the motion or the
recommendation as per the Amendments and
that was on the screen please chair can
I have a a seconder and can we have a
vote by by by Ascension if that's okay
I'll second
second okay uh can we agree um um
chairman I need to I did ask to speak I
need to just point something out okay go
ahead um that on the planning training
and overview and scrutiny training I
think you'll find that we've already
agreed that this has to
happen um planning has everyone who sits
on a planning committee has to have
training yes um otherwise they're not
allowed to vote I think um and overvie
and scru
I think you'll find I think it's the
terms of reference actually say for that
committee that they have to have
training in order to sit on that
committee yes I think you're right I'm a
m and um so we can't have we can't that
last
part you know that's not quite correct
so it says where appropriate external
providers well we've got to have the
training you can't not have it so it
needs to be amended slightly otherwise I
haven't got a problem with it okay count
um leader I think that's what that means
where appropriate so if it's if it's on
an overview and scrutiny committee or if
it's on a planning committee that
members are not allowed to sit until
they've had the training that is where I
assume uh and correct me if I'm wrong
cancer Sidle is what um cancer Sidle
actually means yeah yeah
I'm I'm I'm fitting it within the plan
that's being defined by the officers
already um um all we're saying is is you
if we've got the internal expertise then
we will use that but if it's appropriate
we might go to external providers for
additional training and it's yeah so
it's it's it's saying that this you just
giving a bit more meat to the
recommendations and to the plan that
Cheryl's already put together exactly
okay are happy with that councilor
Benford well I'm just trying to read it
I'm not seeing it very well actually
because it's
bit small very
late very late my eyesight
is thank you T members oh God I mean
couldn't you make it simpler councelor
Sidle no because if you are doing a
training plan you need to know what
you're GNA get before you go on it all
right I just I just want to make it
clear somehow that we have to have
planning and overview and scru training
we can't just leave it for external
providers if we
have so put that for the mandatory
planning and overview and scrutiny
training
yeah okay our members happy to agree
that by assent
yes would like to add standards please I
did ask to add stand standards standards
yeah standards to that please
yes amendment to that was an amendment
to an amendment one at a time please
councilor leader that was an amendment
to an amendment are we all in agreement
for that amendment to be to the original
Amendment
yes code of
conduct yeah now now we're going to give
an you're making it too complicated
members I think in the essence that
councilor Sidle put um the proposal and
I think that if members so see fit you
can um contact whoever the training
department say in your view can we do
that and if it needs to go to council
then can we take it back to council but
if you're going to make it too
prescriptive it's too prescriptive if
you look at if you look at if you look
at the code if you look at the training
plan that's provided in the report
things like code of conduct training is
already in there so it's just about
giving some more detail to that training
so it's already there okay right so um
we're going to
uh can we agree though can we agree this
amendment and and those recommendations
yes agreed agreed agreed put standards
on the list yes it is there yes it is
there it is there okay thank you very
much it's not mandatory the standard
mandatory
right okay uh agenda item
21 just can I just clarify um someone
just mentioned that standards wasn't
mandatory so is that correct so I think
if you T if you look at the the training
um plan that was put together by
cherl then standards is on there but
it's not part of the mandatory I don't
think I can't I can't remember now I
just move so
for yeah yeah are members happy members
happy with that yes yes yeah thank you
recommendations in the report as well is
that right
chairman the training plan as well yeah
yes yeah that's thank you very much just
wanted to confirm okay thank
chairman well
done okay um so the uh I think we're
really almost there uh coid 19 uh
economic recovery car parking um in a
moment I'll call on the leader to
introduce this item uh again if you want
to speak on it please use the chat
function uh leader can you introduce the
report uh very briefly thank you um yes
I'd like to introduce the report for
coid 19 economic recovery car parking
and I'd like to move if um councelor Hol
not counselor Richard Holmes is still
online if he can do a small uh update or
presentation on this I think it's pretty
pretty explanatory but then if he can do
that please I'm sorry I'm getting so
tired
chair thank thank thank you ler and very
very very nearly good morning members um
yes so this report was drafted before um
the latest lockdown announcement was
made so uh I've also done an addendum
which you'll find within the pack at
Pages 31 through 32 however I'll very
briefly take through the r because the
key issue is still relevant but I need
just to highlight a couple of changes to
it so the report looks at uh two areas
specifically um how we can assist local
businesses in the High Street area um
and uh we approach with regarding the
leadup to Christmas uh and reintroducing
the free parking days half or days that
we produced uh for the businesses to
support them um this was given to me as
a delegation but was withdrawn in 2019
so uh the intention is to reinstate the
parking days but actually split it over
six occasions we also had discussions
around Christmas Eve break and we've
been approached specifically by business
to ask if we could also add an extra
date for the afternoon of Christmas Eve
uh to be free parking as well beyond
that we were exploring ideas regarding
how we could help businesses to boost
the evening part of the uh uh training
for them uh and we would like to go out
to consultation um on potentially
bringing the evening charge earlier into
the afternoon you'll see that within the
report um and that could be uh uh one a
week or it could be actually five or six
days a week um and we would take the uh
the consultation back to the working
group itself before it come back to
council so essentially uh that stands
firm but the difference being now of
course now we're in lockdown it might
not be appropriate to run those six half
days in November or December it might be
better to run some in December or even
in January to assist the businesses so
um the recommendations are fine
providing we accept that the dates that
were referenced within the report itself
can be flexible and given I can be given
the delegation working with the
businesses to um to flex those for the
the most benefit of the the businesses
um I thank you to council Fleming for
helping me uh draft that addendum um and
happy to take any
questions thank you I I know that we've
got councelor Lagan Lagan has a question
thank you councelor he um yeah I just
want to comment that this is a really
strong proposal and I like the
flexibility that it brings and anything
that we can do to sort of help uh
promote you the footfall in in the High
Street which is getting bigger and
bigger is a really good thing so this is
really good work good thinking and
should be commended so thank
you thank you councelor Lagan uh
councelor
nun well I concur completely and I thank
uh Richard Holmes for his brief
presentation and I think we should
Empower him to have that level of
flexibility chair and that would be a
proposal from me
I'd like to second that and I would
second that okay thank you councelor
Thompson um no agree thank you um thank
you very much Mr Holmes thank you for
still being with us this morning nearly
um and yes please absolutely agree
including the deleg delegation thank you
thank you and councilor
Fleming thank you chair I just wanted to
take the opportunity to thank the
officers and uh the my colleagues on the
working group uh it was very good group
very
constructive um the proposals are
brilliant um also officers have been
working on a a campaign to run um with
the parking at so we get more bang for
our buk um and yeah it was very positive
also I'd like to take the opportunity to
encourage all members to delay their
shopping slightly to December
and to do it on molden High Street um so
that we can support our businesses so
don't be tempted and
sorry here councelor
St so don't be tempted to click online
delay this year is the year to do it
last minute and to do it on our local
high streets thank
you thank you uh I know that uh
everybody's kind of agreed on that and I
know we haven't spend a great deal of
time on this but this really is an
excellent report and I really do uh take
into account uh the good work that's
gone into that so I do thank you Mr
Holmes and all those uh who all those
who are involved shall I recommend shall
I um put the recommendations um chairman
I'd like to recommend as per the report
and all members comments and thank um Mr
Holmes and the the groups um who's
worked so hard on this and I'd like
members to actually agree to this for
Ascent and unless there are any queries
thank you chair agreed agreed
agreeded
absolutely I'm gonna have to dissent um
I've not got I'm not asking for a
recorded Vote or anything but due to all
the coid bum fluffy I I just can't agree
with this so uh maybe you'd like to note
the minutes that uh councelor Morris
didn't give a sent but everyone else did
thank you that's absolutely fine
councelor Morris and that will be noted
I'm sure thank you very much uh uh
agenda item 22 business by reason of
special circumstance considered by the
chairman to be urgent I'm pleased to say
there is none uh and I'm going to move
to uh our last uh yeah our last matter
uh which is exclusion of the public and
press um the uh under Section 104 The
Local Government Act 1972 to the public
be excluded from the meeting for the
following item of business on the
grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three of part one
of schedule 12a of the act and this
satisfies the public interest test is
that seconded second seconded thank you
thank you very much so we'll uh say good
night uh to members of the public thank
you very much for your attendance if
you're still with us and we'll move into
Clos
session